morning are
you wonderful he I wanted to tell you we
last week you know
here
talking good
morning
are
the across theall I'm gonna be there for
a little bit I just request that when
you come back in if someone is speaking
wait until
they
good morning uh environment and
seats I'd like to start off our morning
with uh the Pledge of
smart
aliance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
all before we start with our hearing i'
just like to
um do a couple of little housekeeping
things um number one I'd like to remind
remind the committee that when people
are speaking uh and and giving their
testimony that if you need to leave the
room or come back into the room and sit
in your seat um it's appreciated if you
wait until the person who is speaking is
done because we don't we want to
minimize the amount of distraction um
and uh just as a matter of courtesy so I
realize that there are times that we
must get up and leave the room for
whatever reason um but when you are
getting up from your seat or returning
to your seat please um respect that the
person uh is
speaking the other thing I wanted to um
just remind the committee as a member of
as a as a point of
decorum is that um people when they come
to
testify
we uh are here to listen to what they
have to say and our our purpose is not
to get into a situation where we are
arguing with them and um so I I would
appreciate that people um keep in mind
that we are here to listen to testimony
and not refute it uh certainly when we
are asking our
questions um also to be mindful that
um our questions should not be any kind
of leading questions at all um they
should just be uh
very quick and to the
point
um and other than that um
I know that we have a very full calendar
coming up uh within the next month we've
got a lot of bills to get
through and I think that there may be
instances where we may have to meet
twice a week instead of once a
week I'm interested to know from the
committee you don't have to tell me
right now but uh
just aside um during the day when we
have breaks or
whatever um is it better for you to come
say a Monday Tuesday or a Tuesday
Wednesday or are there any Are there
specific days of the week that are
not um amenable to you for whatever
reason you know maybe you have
um a job or something
that other things that are going on in
your life but um we we will have to have
uh some instances maybe two or three
times where we will uh need to have a
second day during the week to
accommodate um work sessions or exec
sessions um
and I think I think that's pretty much
all I wanted to cover um before we we
get into our
um into our hearings this morning
representative
smart thank you madam chair um I guess I
just want to apologize to anybody for
last week if I embarrassed any of my
colleagues I'm sorry um C was not my
intent I was just trying to get an
answer so sorry sure thank you for your
apology appreciate
it um and I guess with that uh we can
proceed with our uh with our hearings
this morning so I would like to open up
the hearing for hb1
1572 which is prohibiting using R mRNA
technology in food and requiring the
labeling of lab grown me meat and food
containing insects and here with us this
grion oh and also I'd like to remind
anybody to please silence their
phones thank you good morning
representative gson and um welcome to
environment agriculture good morning
Madam chair I'll put on my spectacle so
maybe I could see everybody over there
oh wrong ones those are my reading
glasses so I'll turn on my bionic eye
this morning everyone's way over there
uh good morning uh Madam chair members
of the committee I am representative
Jeff gon from Grafton County 6 I
represent the towns of Wentworth rumney
and Orford and I here to introduce House
Bill 1572 to you this bill addresses
three areas related to food safety uh
one is the use of mRNA mRNA or messenger
RNA technology in food the second is lab
grown meat and the third is insects as
food uh in addressing mRNA technology
and food the idea of edible vaccines is
not a new idea but it has only been
recently with the invention of mRNA
technology or the use in vaccines uh has
this become more of a
possibility in reality mRNA vaccines are
not traditional vaccines and really
aren't even vaccines they are gene
therapy because instead of introducing
in a in an
injection the a sample of a
virus the
Mr is injected into a person and the
MRNA goes into to the cells and teaches
the cell to produce the spike protein or
the the virus that it will then combat
to provide the the immunity so your body
becomes the producer of the
antibody and the the the
immunization and so this idea of an
edible vaccine would be the the vacine
the MRNA would be injected into the food
supply either into cattle or uh pigs or
the the meat Source or through a genetic
modification of plant cells so you would
get it eating your lettuce or your
arugula or eating your cow either one
you would get
vaccinated and so you this is not about
covid vaccines in particular it just
happens to be this mRNA Tech technology
came about became popularized or or
became part of our our daily uh lexicon
with the invention of the MRNA mRNA
vaccines used for covid but now it as it
supply this
technology while it seems pretty
wonderful does have its side effects and
they they all
as more and more studies are
demonstrating they they are actually
pretty dangerous they're pretty
hazardous we know now that mRNA produces
a spike is related to to covid anyway it
produces the spike protein but
unfortunately that Spike protein is not
limited to just the area in the
immediate vicinity of the injection site
that these these Spike proteins are
either breaking loose or they're being
produced proded in other parts of the
body especially small blood vessels
which then trap blood in that blood
vessel causing blood clots there's also
uh myocarditis is a known side effect of
these mRNA
vaccines uh there then there's also the
link between the vaccine and what is
called long covid it's a Perpetual state
of Mala basically uh a flu like symptoms
uh it's a because your body becomes not
only the producer of the antibody but
also the immune response to to immunize
you your immune system is constantly
stressed and because of that
overstressing it becomes weakened and so
you have this headaches all the time or
some weakness body so those are flu like
symptoms that just perpetuate and
they're calling that long covid but it
is a direct result of these
linked to I should say uh these these
mRNA vaccines so now when you introduce
that into the food supply one you're
doing it against people's knowledge
perhaps against their wishes somebody
who who's already been vaccinated for
covid say uh doesn't need another
injection or doesn't want another uh uh
vaccination whatever somebody who has
not been vaccinated doesn't want the
vaccine and we need to be able to
respect both parties but here if it's in
the if it's just done without knowledge
or without care with just disres
disregard for people's uh desires now
you are consuming something that you may
or may not want that may or may not
produce some kind of an effect how do
you then diagnose what the problem is
and how it came about and so it opens
it's it's a it's not only it's food
safety but it's also infringing upon
as
for the lab grown meat and the use of
insects in
food this bill does not do anything to
prohibit oh excuse me let me back up one
this bill would prohibit the use of mRNA
in the food
supply because it is not proven
technology it is or it has been proven
to not yet be safe enough to be injected
into our food supply
so that's that's a Prohibition against
mRNA for lab grown meat and insects as
food there's no prohibition against
either one uh if somebody wants to eat
lab grown meat and there are definitions
these definitions for lab grown meat uh
includes terms such as cultivated meat
or cell-based meat uh that is from the
actual Labs that are developing this
technology or what have you um
there so that you could see it by
different names but the point is you are
free to eat what you want to
eat it just needs to be labeled what its
source is it's lab grown meat this is
not farmer Fred just slaughtered his his
herd and you're eating that and so that
is a very important distinction because
there is a more process involved and we
need to be able to know just like the
the uh uh the cattle yards have their
inspectors USDA inspectors these Labs
need to have inspections things that are
labeled as uh sourced outside the US
these need to have the labs being
sourced and this lab the only
restriction not only if there has to be
a label on the on the food that it is
lab grown but it also has to have the
information of where that lab is and no
Labs outside the United States and that
is for our own personal safety because
Wuhan as far as
insects this is beyond what the FDA
already allows for The Accidental
insects in your food already for those
of you who are not aware we eat bugs all
the time anyway uh but this would be
where an insect is actually an
ingredient in the food eat all the bugs
you want it just has to be labeled that
that's what you're eating and so just
honesty and integrity and labeling and
that's all I have I'll take your
saitis good morning and thank you um for
your
testimony how prevalent is this is this
new technology is it in New Hampshire
now this is relatively new uh
breakthrough technology if you want to
call it breakthrough It's relatively new
but uh the US government has um invested
taxpayers dollars in the research of
mRNA vaccine vaccines excuse me mRNA
technology to produce foods that
vaccinate that's that's been done for
years now so that is not new in fact the
first article I found was back in the
year 2000 and I know there's things
before that um but
uh so for at least maybe 20 close to 25
years we've been looking at turning food
into into a means of vaccinating people
lab grown meat is a relatively new uh uh
process um but it has been around a few
years and it's being introduced
restaurants there are restaurants uh in
some of the more Chic locations of the
country like a a downtown San Francisco
has one restaurant the New York City has
one restaurant where they are
introducing lab grown meat on their
menus uh as well as insects as well uh
and so it is while it is relatively new
I don't know if it's in New Hampshire uh
it's it's okay that if it comes into New
Hampshire that's not the problem it just
needs to be labeled
properly representative Bixby yeah so um
in terms of the MRNA vacines and uh and
meat so you uh if uh there is for
instance an mRNA ma vaccine that would
protect poultry against Aven flu and
it's meant to Pro protect the animals
bill the purpose of the
vaccinations is designed to get you and
me
vaccinated if the MRNA if they can
demonstrate that mRNA a does not go from
you know if it's if the the poultry is
immunized against Aven flu that it
cannot transfer from the chicken to me
then I guess that wouldn't be a problem
but if they can't prove that then it
becomes a problem because the aim is to
vaccinate you and me thank you
representative I have a question sure
about
um so you have in two sections of this
bill where
You're simply labeling um the item and
that to me is very reasonable why would
you not then just simply have a label
put on an item that uh has the MRNA te
technology or vaccination as opposed to
Banning the the product Al together I
mean we see in the grocery store uh you
know when we buy milk not does not
contain
U product from an animal that was
vaccinated with BST or whatever so um
different because of the safety involved
with or the questions that still arise
of mRNA technology the links
to um the known links between mRNA
injections and blood CL
myocarditis the
perpetu perpetuation of illness whatever
and it begs the question that come to my
mind how do we know what it is that
we're being vaccinated against because
there could be some disease out there
that we don't know about how are we
going to get vaccinated against that we
can only have a vaccine against things
that we
know our body has to produce prod that
antibody so how is it going to know what
antibody to produce and so which animals
are or which plants are we going to
introduce
which Technologies into and so because
there are so many questions about the
safety and perhaps even the efficacy of
mRNA I don't think it's a good idea to
put it in our food
supply we already regulate it we're
already regulating it with with respect
to Medicine you put it in the food
supply and you lose all regulation after
that thank you um I'm not
sure I'm not sure I
understand my my question
was why wouldn't we simply label the
package to to show the consumer that it
the animal or product contains uh
ingredients that came from something
that was vaccinated with
mRNA
technology if if you want wanted make an
amendment to the bill it's in your hands
now I just personally don't like the
idea of somebody injecting something
into me against my wishes because
eventually the food supply is going to
get limited as to what is going to be
available to me than you uh everything
is going to be injected in or it's not
going to be labeled somehow or another I
we have just to give you an example the
the uh the dairy the milk producers are
trying to introduce milk products that
they can add ingredients to milk and
still call it milk and they're trying to
do this without having to label it as
containing some other ingredient besides
milk and I don't mean just adding
vitamin A and vitamin D that get
stripped out during the homogeneization
and pasteurization process so they're
already attempts to to conceal what's
actually ingredients in our
food so you know in an ideal world you
could just slap a label on it this
contains mRNA technology and then one
person buy buys one one person buys the
other but unfortunately what ends up
happening is you be find a shrinking
availability of that which is not going
to have the technology invest injected
into it thank you uh representative
Howard you had your hand up
before thank you madam chair um I
actually have two questions the first is
um is the Mr mRNA in food intended only
for the purpose of vaccination or does
it have other other uses that somehow
like preserve the food or something like
that no it's it is designed as a
vaccination a vehicle for vaccination
Madam chairman yeah follow up is is the
evidence of harm such as long covid
caused by mRNA as you claim it to be
coincidental or is it proven causal no
the the studies are be coming out now
that are linking the two people who who
have uh experienced this long covid and
the common denominator is being the
vaccination thank you representative
bman thank you madam chair I want to
just follow up on that and then I have a
second question if that's okay the first
one was um you said that they're linked
um but there's a very uh different um it
means something different if the
causation versus correlation do you know
if it's causation or
correlation has causation been proven I
should say causation has been linked to
blood clots
um
myocarditis and then the the studies
that are coming out are showing
direct linkage as a causal causal
causational link to the long Co itself
that's the the newest things that are
coming out uh from all these studies
thank you and follow up sure go ahead
thank you this is a different question
but and forgive my naive on this um I
know right now it's pretty popular for
that like impossible meat and the
uh I don't know there's two different
ones um uh which are known to be lab
grown meat Alternatives do you know if
this falls into that category in any way
and or does the bill address it in any
way my understanding of impossible meat
is it is a
plantbased meat protein source so it is
not lab grown
meat unless unless I'm unless I am
yeah they are actually lab grown one of
them I forget the other term there's one
that's impossible and then there's
another term that's similar and one of
them is actually lab grown so um I'm
just wondering if if that would be
addressed in here maybe something to
follow up on I guess so so lab grown
meat is is developed from actual animal
cells it's placed in what's called a a
bioreactor there are other amino acids
and other things that that combine
comine and grow the cells to produce
this meat product impossible meat my
understanding of what that with that is
is actually a plant-based whether it's
be soybean or uh uh peas chickpeas or
something whatever whatever whatever
other source it may be because there are
people who want to have uh plant-based
protein sources and not meat-based
they're they're vegan or vegetarian or
such and so if it actually contains
animal
cells and grown then it this then then
yes this would cover that the the it
would be have to be labeled as lab grown
and the lab would have to be the the the
contact information for the lab would
have to be on the label itself um if
it's just a plant-based product then
this would not be covered it would not
be required to be covered under this
because it's not actually meat thank
you uh representative Murray thank you
madam chair um to follow up on
representative bchan's question I guess
one of the questions I I I think she may
have been alluding to and if I'm wrong
please correct me representative but is
around sort of um the the there are
fungal based things that are also grown
as a meat substitute or alternative so I
maybe that was more to the point like
those are those are not lab grown Meats
it's a completely different process a
completely different
product these they are not developed
using animal
cells and so that is the key to I'm
assuming what you're getting at and what
what you are getting at those are actual
plant-based products and not uh animal
cell-based
products uh represent smart after my
question okay um so I noticed if I if I
read on um the bill line 17
Page I guess it's the just a page of the
bill um line 17 says no food sold in the
state of New Hampshire shall have M RNA
technology added to it would you be
amable to a change to this to say no
food sold in the state of New Hampshire
shall have mRNA technology added to it
for thep purpose of vaccinating the
public because I'm looking at this and
first of
all as I understand no mRNA animal
vaccines are currently available for
Farmers uh and other animal owners in
our
state and to representative bixby's
point I mean there may be um mRNA
technology Gene therapies whatever um
coming to to um the agricultural
Community which would help animals and
prevent them from um having certain
diseases we certainly want to use
whatever tools that are available to um
combat these
diseases so I'm wondering if we should
if we could limit this um and going back
to the the phrase just for the purpose
of vaccinating the
public
the only question that comes to my mind
in that otherwise I I would have no
problem with it is how do we split that
hair because how do we know that by
injecting something into an animal it or
or the manipulation of a plant seed
because there's also mRNA technology in
Plants as well how do we know that that
that does not then transfer itself into
our body so as a byproduct even that it
is vaccinating us against something um
contamination or however whatever it
would be so somebody could say well
we're not purposely trying to vaccinate
anybody by doing this oops it happened
so I'm not I otherwise I agree that I
wouldn't have a problem with just in it
in itself I just don't know how to split
the hair thank you representative
smart thank you madam chair to be
nice um I have a question my question is
um we we label Foods they they put
everything in labels um are supposed to
be there why is mRNA technology why
would that be different or bugs or fake
meat be different in the labeling that
we would have to specify this I mean you
can't even have hormones or you know
antibiotics in our milk they dump it on
the on the milk room floor um before
they take it so I don't understand why
it would be
different do you want to know where your
food comes from oh I do and that's what
I thought the purpose of labeling was so
but my question is why would this these
three items not fall under the
regular they're not that's just the
whole point they're they're not covered
by any labeling requirements now okay
you you cannot go into a grocery store
and find this this
food product contains mRNA this food
product is lab grown meat maybe
eventually it will uh they maybe they
maybe they'll they'll market it that way
um but as it is right now you have no
idea they there's a lot of deception in
labeling too um so when things are
labeled whole grain what does that mean
um non- GMO we we we look for for labels
to say non-GMO well the epitome of GMO
is lab grown meat and mrm a it's
straight up
GMO and and so
um they're they're not being labeled now
and I don't see where they would this
would just require them to be labeled
okay so that way we know where our food
is coming
from okay representative NAB thank you
madam chair um I would just ask I'm not
a physician I don't know that anyone in
this room is or an immunologist or a
biochemist this feels like a subject
where we need a little bit of expertise
and I don't know the Department of
Agriculture is going to be able to
provide it but this concept of the
vaccine transferring from an animal to a
human by consuming the animal is not I
feel like we need a little more
information on it um we certainly don't
want to compromise food safety animal
safety bring diseases into the state um
so I just would ask if we don't get that
information from the Department of
Agriculture or someone else in this room
that we are provided it in another
fashion we would have a work session on
those thank y representative Bixby yeah
so I was wondering um whether there are
current uh labeling requirements in
terms of ingredients that are already
present in FDA uh rules and and laws
that would uh require the labeling of
lab grown meat as such and require the
uh and the use of insects as ingredient
as such and if those already exist would
this bill conflict with those this bill
would that I have been able to find
nothing that would conflict with current
labeling
rules um the
FDA has a what's called a smart label
that that they're introducing how long
it's been around I don't remember um but
it
is basically you you could go up to your
food and it won't really have anything
written on it but it maybe a QR code and
you could scan that QR code and up Pops
the ingredient label it sounds really
simple and great so you can have smaller
but the idea is to make it very
clear what it is you are actually
purchasing there is a difference between
lab grown meat and The Butcher Shop
cut
cow and so because there is a difference
one is just cut the other is
processed there needs to be a
distinction between the two made and
somebody may not have the time or the
ability uh and it just
looks to have to take the time to scan
that QR code hopefully you have Wi-Fi
connection hopefully it comes through
and you can see there's nothing to
interrupt your ability to see what is
actually on that label if it's just
clearly labeled this is lab grown meat
and to go back to the question that the
representative mentioned about we don't
know about the transfer of vaccines into
It's a Wonderful point and I mentioned
it earlier as well and but you bring up
a great point there but we do know that
we have restrictions on hormones that
are given to cat that was brought up
over here as well if milk contains
because it has to be tested if milk
contains the hormones the milk has to
get dumped right there on the floor that
we because we know it transfers those
hormones transfer from the cow to to the
consumer through the milk and so because
there is that risk we know it can happen
there is the risk that it would happen
uh but just uh that's one of the dangers
that must be be fared out before we
allow it to be in put into our
food representative Howard um do we is
there food on the market currently that
contains mRNA technology and and if so
against well that's the
mystery uh unfortunately there's not a
whole lot of forthcoming on whether or
not it's being
used uh there's a lot of
that there are attempts to do it there's
a desire to do it uh whether or how pre
prevalent I'm sure it's been been tested
that's the how we do things we're
supposed to test them uh how widespread
that is I don't know but I have read
articles where herds have been but what
they are being injected I have that I
don't know that's not very clear in the
articles that I've been able to read so
unfortunately the answer is yes probably
how far I don't know and what for I
don't know either because it's just not
the information is just not open
so are you fam is the reason why you put
this bill forward because there's been
uh there has been a lot of conjecture
that's out there um new sources I have
several that I just pulled up um that
they are experimenting with this
technology in animals oh I know they're
experimenting with it it's whether or
not it's being
released out into cons to the for the
consumer to to have
testing testing animals in a laboratory
Farm is one thing that I know they're
doing whether or not they're allowing
that those those cattle or or pigs to be
I don't know if they're doing chickens
yet or not but cattle and pigs uh if
they're being released to the market
that's what I don't know and just
exactly what they are injecting them
what what is the virus they're tried to
prevent is what I don't it's not clear
in any of the Articles I've been able to
find
followup so I have an article here here
that says uh that's talking about it
being tested in pigs and I um myself and
a and a group of other um folks have
reached out to several different
distributors from Trader Joe's to Whole
Foods as well concerning this as well as
concerning um the bugs um we do know for
a fact that the bugs are named
underneath uh certain
um like a you know call it like a an
acronym you know what I mean so we know
that so they're hiding it under that
correct you know whatever those acronyms
are so you have to be careful but uh we
got some really great feedback from some
of the local um that they're keeping an
eye on this of course especially you
know if you're purchasing um
representative Penza do you have a
question so are you familiar with uh any
of the local groceries or whatever that
have had feedback in regards with us
saying that they I have not contacted
any local Grocers okay okay uh to to
find out what they plan on doing or what
products may be available but you are
correct about insects you will not find
on the label uh ingredient number one
crickets unless you're buying a lollipop
it's called a cricet and then it has a
cricket well sugar sucrose artificial
coloring Cricket you can also get
grasshoppers representative
ktoa
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um knowing what the labeling laws are
now
and when we see the hormone labels and
the antibiotic labels some of them state
that no hormones are
added and to me that says they're not
adding hormones but they could be in the
feed or in another source so truth and
labeling I think is extremely important
how would you distinguish if we wanted
to amend this um that you know there
could be mRNA in the food source or
whatever but they're not adding it or
injecting it into the animal how would
you distinguish that and how would we
label for that
information that's a
toughy
uh the cow may not be injected
is that I don't know because you start
peeling back the onion and it goes all
so that one I'm not sure how to handle
but I as far as like for the purpose of
vaccinating the public is a great place
to start inserting that
Clause
um I don't know I don't even know where
the process begins end again we don't
know whether it
transfers we don't know if it transfers
from the from the animal to the person
but we do know that they're trying to
make it so that if you eat that salad
you're vaccinated if you eat that cow
you would be vaccinated and so we know
purpose so does the process begin with
the cow eating the grass than the then
we eat the cow that I don't
Bosman thank you madam chair um kind of
Switching gears here looking at the cost
projected uh for a compliance officer um
could you just looking at it I'm looking
at the salary it looks I'm wondering
where you got those estimates or the
salary pres bman that was put in by um
by the um uh the uh the people who do
the fiscal notes oh I'm sorry so that's
not anything that's put together by the
uh the author of the bill okay and so he
would not know that information I'm sure
that when we have uh folks from
different agencies come in we have
testimony coming you can ask that
question thank you madam chair
representative Penza you had a
question are you familiar with um
Missouri House Bill
1169 I am okay I so I haven't read the
whole thing forgive me but I am familiar
with its intention okay so it's a
fantastic Bill are you trying to model
that bill to here I actually wrote this
before I read that so I I to say that I
modeled it after that
no followup one followup yeah would you
consider having um this pretty much say
that it is um labeling meat or anything
for potential gen therapy product like
we do similar with
hormones so that's what I'm saying like
it's that's what it gets labeled as a
gene therapy product that was in that
was in the meat that was injected into
it
correct my objective is to just prohibit
the use of mRNA the the purposeful
injection of mRNA into the food
supply so it's it's not just a labeling
and then it's okay it's a you're not
going to do it because it is not
demonstrate itself to be safe to use
there are too many unintended
consequences um not having scrutinized
the Missouri Bill enough I don't know
what they are actually trying to achieve
although I i' I've scanned it I know
that it's there there are other states
that are attempting to do the same kind
of thing um it's progress I have no idea
uh each one and hard to follow sometimes
but the objective here is to at this
time say you cannot
inject or use
mRNA in our food supply the intended
purpose being to vaccinate people
against
whatever because we just don't
have a proven track record of it being
safe or
effective okay thank you um and I think
we're done with our questions from the
committee so appreciate you introducing
the bill and answering so many questions
I am I I've got to get back to an
executive session so me ducking out is
not to uh okay tell you guys to pound
sand or anything like that but I am
actually in a in an executive SE
downstairs thank you very much sure have
a good rest of the day and I'd like to
call Colleen Smith from DHHS to come
testimony good morning good morning
Madam chair and members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to provide
information on House Bill
1572 the department is not taking a
position on this bill but we did want to
provide some information around the
fiscal note that was alluded to earlier
um this is very new technology all um
components of this bill the cell culture
cultivated meat is regulated currently
by USDA and FDA there are two companies
in the country that are allowed to make
product and right now we believe it's
very limited in distribution to um
restaurants and specific in larger
cities but it's not it's very um Limited
in
distribution um it is uh as was alluded
to in previous testimony new technology
so we don't know how what the
anticipated um anticipated track this
will take will it be in grocery stores
one day um I understand it it's very
expensive to make this product so it it
might be just in a niche market for
quite some time so we have a lot of
uncertainty about what this would mean
for the Department as far as
responsibilities in regulating this um
currently the two products are chicken
products that are allowed to be made by
these two companies that have been
approved federally to make them and the
labeling is self cultivated chicken that
it needs to be labeled on that product
so that would conflict with um the
language and the statute as directed to
label it as lab grown meat um the also
the second part of this bill that speaks
to mRNA technology we understand that no
mRNA technology is currently approved
for any cattle vaccine and the given the
how a how how this is digested in animal
tissues it would be very difficult for
the Department to know if this
technology was used in producing food so
we have some some concerns what it mean
um like a traceback with individual
Growers to make sure that their animals
that they were using for food um didn't
use this
technology and then the final component
is the allowance of insects So currently
we're not aware of any producers in New
Hampshire offering insects but it is um
available in other parts of the country
or world but they would ALS so have to
be from an approved source and would be
required to be labeled on a product um
if they were to be used as an ingredient
they'd have to be demonstrated that they
were inspected there was no food safety
issues with using that component if they
were able to be used in food um so we
did put in a because the department
would be charged with enforcement of
these three components we did put forth
a fiscal note to include an inspector
who would be charged with um enforcing
these three these three areas and again
just want to stress that they're very
novel so we're very we're uncertain as
to um what this would entail for us not
only now but you know years to
come and happy to take any questions the
committee has representative
brard thank you madam chair uh now you
said the uh in a couple of largest
cities um they are currently serving lab
grown meat uh is the consumer
aware so so what we know is that it's a
it's in restaurants and again I believe
it's just n Niche and I would I I'm not
familiar with those two restaurants but
I would I would expect that probably it
is disclosed because that would be the
in people there are people that are
seeking out um cell cultured meat as a
alternative sorry in New Hampshire no no
not in New Hampshire so I'm only aware
of San Francisco in Washington DC as
having restaurants offering this product
I'm not aware that it's distributed in
New Hampshire
currently represent
piby so I'm wondering about um whether
mRNA uh in a particular form would
actually survive the process of being
consumed and because I my understanding
is that you know first you're dealing
with stomach acids and then there are
enzymes called mRNA Aces that are very
active at breaking down foreign mRNA so
it is my understanding I'm not an expert
in animal vaccines but in researching
this bill and contacting the USDA it's
my understanding that the vaccines don't
persist in animal tissues at all so that
even by cons they wouldn't be to in the
final product um so that's from our
standpoint it would make it a challenge
how how would we test for this or we'd
have to basically look at records of
producers to know if they had been
vaccinated using an Mna technology if it
were to be approved in the future thank
you representative NAB thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um could you just clarify the insect
labeling you said they have to be
labeled is that as an insect product or
just they have to be labeled as any
other food prodct be just as any other
food ingredient it would have to be
labeled as a component of the food okay
thank you and um so Miss Smith when they
label this
component would they is is there a
requirement for them to actually say
something like crickets or do they give
their scientific name for crickets or
you know whatever it would be the common
name the common name of the they would
have to use the common name yeah okay
thank you any other questions for Miss
Smith senan thank you for your testimony
today and I'd now like to call um
commissioner Sean Jasper from Department
of
morning good morning Madam chairman
members of the committee I am Sean
Jasper commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food I am taking
a position on on this bill uh primarily
due to the fact that if you were to pass
it it would severely limit the food
options for people in the state of of
New
Hampshire um which feeding people is
very important to me and I and I say
that because we have to recognize that
we're country of what 330 million people
we're a state of 1.4
million so if we just think about that
and you put something like this on a
requirement many companies would will
simply not come to New Hampshire anymore
they will not send their product into
New Hampshire we've had this
discussion for many years over certain
labeling requirements within the New
Hampshire legislature and that really
always comes back to that New Hampshire
is not California people are not going
to do things simply because New
Hampshire says it I I've unfortunately
sent a link to you or an email to you
later I had sent to the chairman because
I couldn't find a link for the whole
committee and it was pretty uh timec
consuming to try to paste all of your
emails in so I sent it this morning I'm
not sure if the if you can just CL click
on the links or not you might have to
copy and paste but there are some here
and one is called the MRNA conspiracy
theories and I I'm going to go right
back to to the beginning here and I'm
going to be longer than I thought
thought after hearing the testimony of
the the the
sponsor anything that you put into
animal feed comes with a
cost Farmers just don't go out and buy
things gee it sounds great there is a
reason and so for anyone to believe that
someone or the government was going to
try to use this technology to vaccinate
all of us would come at a cost somebody
would be getting paid there need to be a
budget line and I would suggest to you
that this would be the most ineffective
way to vaccinate the population because
you'd have to know that everybody was
going to be eating a certain product or
certain products to get there and it
would still be very costly and in
inefficient and obviously every time you
ate the same product you're getting
vaccinated again and in an extreme cost
so I would suggest that there is no idea
out there currently that we would would
be vaccinating people against against
their their will through this method
we've also heard from uh HHS that it's
not something that's currently available
um it's being being talked about and I
know that um there is there are
discussions going on with within the uh
National Association the state's
Departments of Agriculture there was a
meeting hosted which in included Merc
which I would assume would be one of the
primary companies who would be
interested in this Tex is is looking at
it but we can't
be out there doing these
things and expecting to have a positive
res result for the consumers of New
Hampshire I would suggest that um if
people were concerned about these things
and there was a market for it then the
opposite would be true is people would
be um labeling their products saying you
know that not containing m&as or
anything else I mean we we cannot expect
to go in this direction but I also would
um would point out as I think the
representative from HHS did there's not
going to be any way to know if this is
this is true and maybe everybody just
stopped sending anything into New
Hampshire at a
$10,000 um fine or requiring labeling
because how is the meat process are
going to know what that animal was fed
there's no current requirements to say
well what was the
ingredients you know there are certain
things that the government requires but
that's at the federal level if this is
not a
federal um requirement then nobody is
going to know go to lame and gos town
are they going to know what those cows
were fed or those pigs or they're not
and there's no requirement to do that so
we could be disrupting our food chain
significantly with anything like this
even when it comes to labeling because
people aren't going to know and if you
require them to do something that they
cannot reasonably know then they're
simply going to withdraw from the market
questions any other questions
representative
kraton thank you uh for your testimony
as always it's enlightening the
um so the so disruption of the food
chain not good um but for these two
labels insects and manufactured meat
those seem like
very
small I mean the manufactured meat
served in two places in the United
States one of which is not New Hampshire
insects are not served in New Hampshire
as far as testimony says so how big a
deal is that is that like a sky is
falling or is that a smaller deal yeah I
I'm not as concerned about the insect
labeling and again I I think you heard
that that would be required coming into
New Hampshire now so I don't I don't
think we want to reinvent the wh and you
need to certainly look at that um
certainly you know that's something that
wouldn't be as disruptive because I
don't think we're going to ever see that
become a mainstream staple of the diet
in New Hampshire sure thank
you any other questions representative
brard thank you madam chair uh Mr
commissioner would you believe that it
was important enough for us Congressman
Thomas Massie to file an amendment to
the uh house agriculture Appropriations
Bill amendment number 86 that states
none of the funds made available by this
act may be used to fund Any Grant
related to any transgenic edible
vaccine oh I I would certainly believe
that and I believe that there are
thousands of amendments um offered all
the time and if Congress passed that
then then great but I also believe that
this is Congress is the only place you
know the federal government is the only
place where something like this can be
effective the state of New Hampshire can
cannot be effective in doing this we can
only harm our our food food chain and
that starts
potentially right here with our own
local slaughter
houses represent na thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um you know there's a fiscal note
attached to this bill but I wonder if
you could speak at all to what it costs
producers to have to label products or
test products what the impact on them
financially is I don't have any
expertise in in that area you know I was
a little puzzled by the um by the fiscal
note because it would seem although we
just heard there's probably no way to
test test it so I'm not sure what the
inspector would doing that is doing
because that would be literally if there
was the technology to enforce this bill
every single piece of of meat coming
into the state or even being produced in
the state would need to be tested to be
in full compliance um and I would think
that that would be significantly higher
than just the cost of an
employee follow up that's a cost that's
born by the producer right the testing
well I don't think so because I I don't
with without the
authorization you know perhaps perhaps
you could look at it that way and say
everybody would be required to do that
right now this bill my reading of it
just says you can't bring it in so it
doesn't say that every producer shall
test their product to ensure so I I
think it would be on the state if we
were going to
uh require
this any other questions for the
commissioner represent
Penza so in regards with the comments I
think from DHHS and then that you
reiterated in regards with like the bugs
um it doesn't say on ingredients
crickets it doesn't say grasshoppers so
it literally is a it's like a code like
let's say if it said MEC or whatever so
um
I think transparency and labeling is
important so do you have a problem with
that well I you're gonna have to tell
people what it is well you know again I
think for anything coming into New
Hampshire you're going to limit limit
the market if you do something different
than the other you know 47 States at
least um on the Continental un us um
Hawaii and Alaska may be a little bit
different but uh
um right now if you look it it most of
the ingredients you know they
use not the common names on most
ingredients on any package usually gives
you something that's you know most of us
have no idea what that is so to
use um a common name because I think
there's probably not one type of cricket
and so you couldn't just say cricket
you'd have to go back to to you know the
genus and the species I suppose and
we're not going to understand that so
again I just I don't think that New
Hampshire can can be an island of
labeling any other questions for the
commissioner representative com
tool thank you madam chair and thank you
commissioner for taking my question um
my question uh regarding all of the
labeling requirements is my concern over
the smart labeling that's coming out
with the QR codes where where the
ingredients will no longer be listed on
the
product but you would have to scan a QR
code while
shopping how would we how would that
because that would be rapidly done by QR
code ingredients coming into different
states could be changed immediately
because they're on a QR code um so
what's the positives and the and the
negatives please well I certainly would
hope
that as that
technology progresses the federal
government would um look at that and
make sure that if there were changes to
what was approved by the uh FDA there
would be severe fines if those QR codes
were changed we're not going to be able
to stop technology I don't particularly
like that idea that I wouldn't be able
to just look at something but if that is
what is allowed by the federal
government then that's what we're going
to have to live with and hopefully
um if they do that they put those
necessary fines in place I mean I
without fines without consequences yeah
you're probably right people can can
change things you don't know to what to
what end but um that's a technology that
is probably going to uh be with
us just quick
followup thank you madam chair and thank
you commissioner um I agree with you I
like to see the labels
listed but Mike what I have heard and I
don't know if you've heard the same is
that part of the reason for the QR code
on different products is so that if
they're making one batch with one
specific set of products and another
batch with another they've changed the
ingredients out they can then put a
different QR code on that
so you could be buying the same product
but have two two separate ingredients
because the QR codes are different and
have you heard anything about that I
have
not thank you all right uh any other
questions for the commissioner I think
we're kind of finding ourselves out of
time and appreciate you coming and
speaking with us today thank you so I
have no other pink cards I'm going to
close the hearing on hb1
on oh yes um the online and I need the
um was uh let's see
seven let me
again
so what do you have you have online
seven in support seven4 yes seven in
support of the
bill and four in opposition to the bill
I'm sorry two neutral and two
neutral and that was
online and um on our blue
here
okay
okay and to introduce the bill today is
representative
kulan who is sponsor of the bill hello
and good morning everyone thanks for
being here today by name is Matthew
kulan I represent Grafton 5 and uh the
prime sponsor of HB 1565 which is also
known as the right to Homestead Act and
I'll start by reading my testimony here
um current New Hampshire law allows a
person to bake and sell a loaf of bread
but prohibits them from making and
selling a delicious sandwich I'd like to
change that HB uh
1565 aka the right to Homestead Act
affirms an individual's right to buy and
sell homemade foods in a variety of
Market settings it adopts a permissive
approach instead of our current Pro
prohibitive one which heavily favors
large scale Agriculture and conventional
Grocers New Hampshire's Homestead food
statutes are dated and difficult for
Farmers Market managers and retail store
owners to understand leading to
incorrect interpretation of statutes
which hurts our local food producers it
makes their delicious products difficult
to Market additionally our current
statues um and incentivized producing
sugary and unhealthy Foods over
nutritious home-cooked or plant-based
meals the right to Homestead Act
corrects this by repealing the homestead
license hereby Shifting the state's
Focus to enforcing transparent labeling
requirements it is estimated by the USDA
that New Hampshire produces between four
and 6% of its own food this amount is
far too low and poses a serious threat
to to our state's food security allowing
the sale of potentially hazardous foods
uh AKA refrigerated Foods creates an
entrepreneurial Gateway for granite
Staters of all walks of life it has the
real potential to introduce people to
new and exciting Cuisines while giving
the next generation of culinary upstarts
ground floor access to an exciting
industry as for Farmers the state of New
Hampshire has about 4,000 Farms most of
which are small operations making less
than $10,000 a year the right to
Homestead Act can help transform our
existing small farm infrastructure into
a vital and resilient network of local
food vendors and Artisans it may also
make it easier for Grassroots
organizations to provide meals and
mutual Aid to neighbors and communities
in need similar policies have been
enacted in many States including Montana
California Maine and others which have
resulted in higher cases of people
feeding one another with no rise in
foodborn illness it's in the interest of
growing the amount of food produced in
New Hampshire uh in which I present HP
1565 and ask the members of this
committee to consider supporting the
people of New Hampshire's right to
Homestead and with that I will open it
up to any
committee representative
bman thank you madam chair and thank you
representative and again I'm this is my
third committee day so trying to learn
all the rules all good yeah um can you
tell me um it's uh how do you what are
you thinking in terms of how we make
sure that the food is safe if we're if
we're bringing if we're decreasing this
regulation the bill actually
outlines uh like pages of guidelines for
how uh products ought to be labeled so
we're moving towards strengthening
labeling uh requirements and I think
that we can actually um satisfy all the
needs of a license by strong labeling uh
requirements so we can Define um these
requirements in statute uh with without
uh needing to have the license anymore
thank
you
represent uh yes thank you oh can you
hear me sure yeah okay uh how does that
what you just said representative how
does that correspond with I believe it's
it's page one line 24 and 25 the
production and sale of Homestead food
products in accordance with this
subdivision are exempt from all
licensing permitting inspection
packaging and label laws in the
state uh how does that jive with what I
just said I mean yeah because I I
thought you said that there would be
labeling requirements but here this says
it's an exemption so I'm a little
confused um page two of the bill
outlines all of the uh requirements and
exemptions and all the good stuff in
[Music]
there representative Howard thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
um I like this idea a lot I and I've
heard from my constituents that they um
that they supported as well a lot of a
lot of those kind of businesses in my
district um I work in a restaurant where
um the owners the lead people are
required to have a safe service
certificate could that something like
that that be included in this
or um I would like it not to be included
in the bill but uh as it states in the
bill that uh nothing in this bill should
stop uh any collection of information or
of people's names and addresses and
things like that and also we have we do
have local control and uh self-
inspecting communities as well so there
is oversight so that bill will not
affect uh certifications like
nav oh did you have a followup no okay
no thank you thank you madam chair thank
you for taking my question could you
just speak to on the first page lines 30
through 31
so does that allow for someone to have
up to a thousand chickens that they're
selling and it's that annual what is the
meaning of that
yeah thanks for the question uh this
part uh part three actually outlines the
federal requirements so we're in
compliance with federal laws and
guidelines so that starts off with the
1,000 bird Rule and then there's two
other requirements are related to
poultry and poultry byproducts so by
outlining um these federal guidelines we
make it so uh we're in compliance with
the feds and also it's saying basically
that you know you can't shoot a deer and
serve like wild game Chile you know as
good as that might sound it's not
covered underneath this bill because we
government
followup so you could have up to a
thousand chickens is that yeah that's
the current federal rule so someone can
process a thousand chickens that
USDA law right now all right thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair so I just wanted to go back to
your question you just said something
about wild game Chile yeah um however
there are USDA inspection facilities for
Wild game so how are you parsing that
delineation out um I think it's I
believe it's covered in uh part A B and
C of part three where saying um it needs
to come from an inspected uh Source such
as a butcher shop grocery
situations okay okay represent
Duty uh yes thank you um over the past
couple of sessions we've done a lot of
work in terms of making Homestead laws
more lenient okay and not sub subject to
licensing so I'm really confused about
this bill and can you kind of hone in on
why you see a need for it and why the
existing laws um prevent um you know
home uh homesteaders from increasing
their um you know profits and their
revenue uh well yeah we did actually do
some good work um regarding Cottage
Foods last session and the cottage Foods
Community was really happy with all of
us on this committee actually so
congratulations everyone um but yeah I
mean farmers and local farmers have been
marginalized by industrialized food so
if you can see that you know 94 to
96% of food in New Hampshire is not
local that's actually that's a food
security issue so the intent of the bill
is to provide a market-based solution to
production okay any other questions
represent Katon I just want to elevate
at the 30,000 ft to make sure my simple
mind understands essentially what you're
saying is if I want to sell food that I
make in my own kitchen that I'm good to
go as long as I meet those exceptions on
page two it's got to be labeled right
and you know you've listed them all out
but as long as I do that I can open up
and sell on the sell that food out of my
kitchen yep okay in certain
situations gotcha okay thank
you any other questions representative
Bixby so one of the things that um we've
done in terms of uh making sure that uh
Homestead food
uh is uh and and and um uh is is safe
and or or if there is a problem that it
is the problem is very limited is by uh
restricting the circulation of the food
to direct Market situations such as
selling directly from the home selling
directly at a farmer's market um and you
have here that uh in um
section on page two uh section 4 a Roman
4 a that uh it could be sold on the
internet uh or by a third party vendor
including a retail store or grocery
store and I'm wondering uh whether that
maintains that connection with the
farmer or the the producer that we rely
on for safety yeah so it does
specifically state that um more
perishable foods that contain dairy and
meat uh need to be sold direct to
Consumer but that uh plant-based or like
baked goods things like that can be sold
uh retail so I do think there is a
protection in there for for that and um
yeah I mean myself I was a market
Gardener for 10 years that's my
experience and that's how I know about
this issue so it's always just you know
I could go to a farmers's market and
sell like lettuce and tomatoes and peas
or something separately and someone can
buy a thing of tomatoes and just stand
there and eat them but if I mixed those
together and sold them as a salad I
would be like violating a law so uh know
just another another point
there yeah representative neb thank you
madam chair um it says in the fiscal
note that this removes the fee for
Homestead operators um which is a loss
of revenue for the state and I I feel
like this bill is making things more
permissive for Homestead
operators do you really think the $150
is a barrier to
entry and what was the thinking behind
removing them having I just think that
if we can outline labeling requirements
that basically satisfy the license uh
the need of license sure then that's
really not too big of a problem
[Music]
here okay representative
dsy yes thank you uh on on uh page three
starting with line eight um you say uh
nothing in the subdivision shall be
conscrew to impede the Department of
Health and Human Services in any
investigation of food born illnesses but
then you say that the fine is
$75 for each so if I'm providing
Homestead food and it has an ill you
know foodborn illness in it I can only
be fined
$75 uh correct anyone that so you don't
need to have a license to have a
complaint filed against you anyone can
have a complaint filed against them uh
with food uh food protection uh Bureau
and um I also got some was able to get
some data on the homestead food
producers complaints from uh
DHHS and I found that uh from
2022 to um October of this year there
were 30 complaints so in a little over a
year there are 30 complaints 29 of those
complaints were people unclear on our
current statute so it's people
complaining about other people selling
stuff that they they're confused about
one of only one of those complaints was
for a health concern so we're doing
we're doing pretty good so I think we
have an opportunity
to open things up a little bit and grow
the market a bit I'd like to see uh New
Hampshire producing 10% of its own food
so any other questions representative K
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative kulon um is it true that
currently uh homesteaders are exempt
from
licensing and do not have a dollar limit
uh for
sales uh they're exempt from licensing
for certain things like uh shelf stable
things uh like Breads and jams and
jellies and things like that yes but
this is opening it up to um you know
cooked meals and things like
that okay any other
questions seeing none thank you for
introducing your bill to us today and I
would like to know and I would remind
you too that now you may not return to
your chair and ask questions
so um I would Now call Smith and Katrina
Hansen from
DHHS to speak on their opposition to
this
bill good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
again my name is Colleen Smith I'm the
administrator for the food protection
section within the Department of Health
and Human Services and I'm joined today
by Katrina Hansen she's the chief of our
in infectious disease surveillance
section and she would be able to speak
to any questions that come up with
regard to foodborn illnesses so so the
department is opposed to 1565 as written
there are several concerns U first I'll
lay out exactly what is allowed
currently by Homestead food producers So
currently a homestead food operation is
allowed to make foods which we call
non-p potentially hazardous or
considered shelf stable they don't
require refrigeration for safety their
items think like things like baked goods
brownies cookies jams jellies candy that
a producer can make in their own home
without a license to sell at retail
stores to uh from their own home to
farmers markets or from their own Farm
Stand if they want to sell to a
restaurant or via the Internet where
there's no direct cons consumer um Baker
or manufacturer relationship interaction
or it's like a a direct mailing they can
do that but they just need to have our
license and currently we have 145
licensed Homestead operations in in the
state's jurisdiction remember there are
15 cities and towns that have their own
authority around this and some of those
cities and towns don't allow Homestead
operations for um a variety of reasons
could be zoning could be they they just
have made that decision not to allow
home food
operations um the we have worked very um
hard with this committee over time to
allow small producers to have an easier
um easier Pathway to being able to offer
their food in Commerce uh a homestead
operation doesn't have to have a
commercial kitchen it can be their
regular residential kitchen their
regular refrigerator their regular um
sink um we allow them to have pets in
the home they just have to secure them
away in an area when they're making
their food and sanitized surfaces um
prior to their food production we are
very concerned about opening the avenue
to allow foods that require
refrigeration for safety or things like
acidified Foods um such as canned pesto
these things have a higher risk of if
done improperly to cause botulism which
it could lead to death of a consumer and
certainly we have at our heart is um
while these Foods could be sold if if
this bill were to pass they could be
sold at restaurants they could be sold
at retail stores any any food born
illness outbreak is not only damaging to
those directly impacted but it's also
damaging to the reputation of New
Hampshire's food supply as a whole um we
we take um our responsibility very very
seriously and those that we license and
inspect and holding them to food safety
standards without a licensing and
inspection system for these Homestead
producers who could make sandwiches in
their home there's there's no guarantees
and really our enforcement it would be
extremely difficult we wouldn't it would
be really by complaints or if we had
food bone illness outbreaks that we
would know if someone was violating
these statutes because we have we have
no we would have no inventory we
wouldn't know how many are out there um
so for these reasons we have concerns
about expanding the offerings that home
food producers can do there are several
commercial kitchens in New Hampshire
that do allow to that are allowed uh
they allow produ home um small producers
to rent space in a commercial setting to
offer Tok Marketplace um we license
those we have the opportunity to have
those dialogues to um have answer
questions food safety questions th this
would take all of that off the table if
if folks could do that without having
our license and
inspection um I would be happy to answer
any questions that the committee has
representative Bixby yeah so
um if someone has a has one of the
homestead food licenses which is like
$150
are they allowed to um produce uh the
the um potentially hazardous foods no
they're still limited to only making the
those that are shelf stable like jams
jellies cookies Etc thank
you representative NAB thank you madam
chair so when the figure on complaints
was cited earlier that would really just
have been complaints about those shelf
stable operations correct not
necessarily so often we get complaints
from other uh it could be community
members could be other folks that are
making Homestead food operations about
other vendors selling products that
require refrigeration and so those are
those are the complaints that generally
we get concerning home food operations
that they're making that they're making
Foods um beyond what they're Allowed by
law to
make representative sofikitis
thank you madam chair do we have
um a lot of um food born
illness so certainly and and I'll have
Katrina jump in if she if she would like
we since we don't allow any um foods
that are what we call potentially
hazardous or require refrigeration for
safety there's not a lot of data about
foodborn outbreaks we have had
historical foodborn outbreaks um we had
one uh many many years ago where someone
made pulled pork in their home and then
made Whole pork sandwiches was
improperly cooled again we only domestic
refrigeration's required they're not
they're not expect a home food is home
food operation doesn't have um a you
know Commercial Refrigeration to make
sure that things are are cooled properly
sometimes there might not be the food
safety knowledge there from that
producer it's a lot different than to
make food for your family versus to make
it for hundreds of of
people hi thank you uh Katrina Hansen
for the record I over see infectious
disease surveillance so we we do have we
have had few outbreaks associated with
homestead foods but I think that is also
a success that we have really food that
right now is available that is lower
risk but this bill allows food that
could be higher risk as Colleen
indicated um particularly meat and and
other products that are typically tied
to foodborn illness in regards to our
statistics uh bearing in mind that most
food born illnesses and also water born
illnesses really kind of fall under this
anic pathogens several of them have to
be reported under our existing statute
RSA 141c so we do have data on these um
but many of these are typically under
reported and that is because of several
reasons which I can answer later if you
have further questions but typically we
see around 300 or so cases of campor on
a 10year average um shika toxin
producing EOL or estc we've had seen 33
of those cases um salmonella 212 over
the past 10 years um the last case of
bachis was infant botulism in 2021 um
not associated with food products since
that's a separate type of illness um but
though we're seeing some reduction in
waterborne illness we have actually seen
an increase of our anic pathogens
particularly salmonella encrypt and um
salmonella and C campor those have been
increasing over the past 10
years thank
you represent
Penza would you um mind sending that
information to the committee of all
all of the confirmed cases because I
that my one of my questions was there is
you know when you can tell me the
confirmed case of botulism and I can't
find anything at all for food warant at
all in New Hampshire sure yeah I looked
back to 2001 and I did not see any cases
of foodborn botulism in New Hampshire to
that point I am still looking into that
I but we do also publish all of our
communicable diseases as required under
RSA 141c and I'd be happy to share that
report to you it is published monthly
and it's over the last 5 years but if
you're if you're looking for more data
we'd be happy to complete a data request
for you and provide you all that data
and then I can also share what I
presented
here okay yeah quick followup yeah um so
this is going to be like where they took
place right I don't want to just see the
numbers I want to like so it would have
like listed on here
2019 at the Puritan back room the neuro
virus death and the 19 so don't we see
that most of these things are happening
um in restaurants and we don't really
have this a homebased
thank you for that question that's a
it's it's a very good question and
insightful so we we do do our best to
track location and where foodborn
illness may have been acquired from but
it's not always that easy it can be
really difficult particularly a lot of
these foodborn illnesses can take three
to five days sometimes a week before
someone experiences signs and symptoms
and by the time they usually typically
seek health care if they do which is
also rare I mean most people let
foodborn diarrheal illness run its
course um if they do seek Health
Healthcare may even be two weeks from
when they ate a particular food item and
at that point most people don't remember
what they ate I know for myself I may
struggle with what I ate yesterday so it
can be very challenging to pinpoint the
many multitudes of products that can go
into eating one food item so one
sandwich may contain multiple food
products and that can be very difficult
but we also do our best with not not
only individual cases but outbreaks we
try to identify um the the ideology of
the of what is causing illness so we do
try to request human specimens
particularly stool specimens and if we
can food items if there is a potential
outbreak or concern about an outbreak we
do have capability in our Public Health
lab to do typing and linking to see if
they're directly Associated but to even
acquire those um those clinical
specimens and then also acquire the food
specimens can be very challenging and
rarely do we really get both of them
often food items are often discarded by
the time an individual seeks care and we
have all of those specimens so we do our
best and we can try to pinpoint it but I
will say majority of our out out breaks
or even investigations we don't have a
very clear sense exactly what is causing
that
illness okay um I I have a quick
question to um for do are you aware of
any states that have a more lenient
um uh statutes than we do on food on the
this food safety Homestead foods that
kind of thing that are experiencing
higher rates of reporting of
illness so
I I can't speak to that correlation I
can speak to there there are there there
is um a website on the association of
food Food and Drug officials that covers
all Homestead regulations throughout the
country and looking at New England New
Hampshire is is on the more lenient side
as to what is allowed and especially
without any kind of licensing and
inspection um Vermont our neighbor it
allows does allow allow some some
products to be made in a home kitchen
that are considered potentially
hazardous but there's also a licensing
and inspection process associated with
that along with a monetary limit as to
how much they can produce um without a
license so so C certainly um I think
every single state in the country has
some sort of Homestead food legislation
that um has passed but they're all very
very um different in what is allowed
especially with without a license at all
okay thank you representative Bixby yeah
how do uh events like um Church potluck
or that sort of thing where people
provide make food in their home and then
provide it to others for uh a one-off
event uh how does that fit in with the
current uh food safety
laws so in that instance there is an exe
current exemption from license Ure for
what's called an occasional Food Service
event so a product so something like a c
a church potluck would fall into that
licensing exemption and and therefore
there's no U there's no requirements
around food that might be even prepared
at the event on site or if it was made
at someone's home and brought to to the
event so that's currently allowed if it
fits under that occasional Food Service
event definition okay thank you any
other questions representative NAB thank
you madam chair um I just wonder if you
see any Middle Ground here I mean I
respect representative kolin's goals
around food Security in New Hampshire
and US producing our own food and I also
respect the uh keeping consumers safe
and your experience and opinion so um I
just wonder if you have any thoughts
about like what Vermont's doing is that
something that would be safer or a
possible path I would say I again
Vermont is one is more lenient than New
Hampshire sure if you look at the other
New England states we we um we are less
restrictive for sure we have a lot of
concerns about opening that that gateway
to allow the the um sandwiches for
instance uh you might it might seem easy
to to prepare a salad or cut but there's
you know produce has been implicated in
several outbreaks it's you have to cut
that tomato you're introducing anything
that's on the outside of that knife
right directly into it um and also what
what temperature is that food to allowed
to be at again with with just allowing
basic um home kitchen we all know homes
can be they can have entry to Children
pets there's a lot of um factors that
could there's a lot of factors that come
into play when when making food in a
home kitchen and then being able to
offer it Beyond just your your own home
home um
Family representative Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you taking my
question additionally I wonder if you
could speak to I'm thinking about um
things like cured meats versus uncured
meats and would the disease pathogens be
different for one of those if they were
held uh at different temperatures or for
a different length of time for
example so curing meat
is is a can is a more specialized
process because with a cured meat it
there are instances where it can be held
um under without Refrigeration however
again that has to be done correctly you
have to make sure you're adding the the
right amount of salt um it's not that it
could couldn't be done safely but there
should be some kind of food safety o
oversight and again making sure that
that food is coming from an approved
Source um there's a lot of other there's
a lot of other uh good operating
procedures that having that that's why
we would require licensing inspection
for an activity like
that followup go ahead thank you um and
thank you particular taking my question
my other question is around internet
sales the non-direct to Consumers um
what type of oversight do you have of
internet sales for food
products as far as as far as once it
leaves the state is that in state or out
of state so what for food coming into
state so I first I'll take the part food
coming out of state by internet sales
directly to someone's home we have very
little to know
um oversight over that that would fall
to the federal government as far as food
crossing state lines um when it comes to
the out of go those that are Manu
manufacturing um and are selling food
with our license it would be the same
type of oversight that we would for
someone producing um food for a
restaurant so we're we're looking at
their food to make sure um talking to
them about how they're preparing their
food how they're cleaning their surfaces
how they're labeling their food products
um we ask that they you know again keep
pets away clean their surfaces that that
would anything if they're if they're
selling um via the Internet they would
again have that type of inspection and
relationship with
US Representative
kraton thank you madam chair and thank
you for your testimony and your
time so I really respect the idea of
allowing
folks to get their product out the
market but I also very much respect your
opinion your experience on the the the
safety associated with that so on the
scale from selling it at a farm stand to
selling it at a farmer's market to then
maybe a restaurant or a long-term you
know grocery store is there a cut off
there where that safety is reduced
maybe if you're selling it straight on
the at a farmer's market versus it's
going to sit on the shelf for two weeks
at the grocery store and is there a way
that that the bill could be modified to
reduce that
risk over certainly I can speak to over
over the past several years is that
there there has been a lot of emphasis
on letting the consumer make that
decision um if they go to a farmer's
market they can meet the person that's
actually producing the food and and make
that decision it's all and there's also
a labeling requirement that it has to
say it's it's exempt from licensing and
inspection once you get removed from
that whether it be at a restaurant or a
grocery store you you don't have that AB
the consumer doesn't have that there's
not that much transparency even though
there is that labeling requirement to to
make that decision decision and then
also the potential it it could um you
know certainly be there could be more
people impacted um if you with with um
greater volumes of food being produced
that c certainly that makes the more the
more food you produce the more people
you're serving um so a scale up would be
you know definitely concerning to us
from a food safety
standpoint okay thank you representative
kto thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question you stated that
Homestead licenses have the same require
oversight as
restaurants um I believe that you stated
no I I can clarify if you if you'd like
thank you so we have we have an
inspection process but they don't have
the same re a homestead food operation
doesn't have the same basic equipment
requirements as a restaurant would and
it's um and it's inspected less
frequently than a a restaurant is as
well again there's also the um manager
food safety manager certification that's
not required for a homestead food
operation but it is required for a
licensed restaurant or a retail food
store follow up uh thank you for that
information um so you're saying you said
that a homestead is inspected less often
than a
restaurant so because they are limited
to making lowrisk Foods they're
inspected at we all of our
establishments are expected on a
risk-based um frequency so you know
certainly a a a store um you know just
from comparison State a store that's
only selling um eggs and bread and milk
would be inspected less frequently than
a a fullscale grocery department that
has you know multiple departments Bakery
meat room produce so we have uh we to to
dedicate our staff to the highest
risk facilities first we have a tier and
so homee seters are are inspected less
frequent than um you know a fullscale
grocery store
um follow up thank you madam chair thank
you again thank you for that information
um I have heard testimony in this
committee before that restaurants uh a
lot of them are expected only once every
3 years can you expound on the
inspection of
restaurants so our inspection frequency
right is rest there are some restaurants
depending on the the their menu it every
every two to one year the those that are
inspected every three years would be
your anybody that's not um preparing
food for instance like a a pharmacy that
they might sell um bacon and meat and
eggs but they're not doing any food prep
that that would be a tier that would be
inspected every three years one last
followup thank you madam chair and is
the inspection schedule and what
restaurants have been inspected when in
dates on listed on at the department so
that we could have access to that
information so we do have restaurant
inspection results available on our
website so so that they are it's public
information okay thank you
representative Howard um would there
would it be possible to make tweaks to
this um build to gain your um support or
is it is it just too far in in the
direction of
unsa well I I would like to offer is
that we we've had
we've made many changes to this the Home
Food statute over over time um you know
certainly we are amenable to anything
that feels that if if those feel there
needs to be Clarity in so that there's
not confusion we would definitely be
amenable to um to helping those home
food producers that might be making um
cream pies and they don't know to to
change things so things are more clear
um I I would offer just like that we
last year we remove the limit without a
license is is that we let um that we
don't make any changes in the this
session but explore maybe if if there
are things that are unclear is is work
to make some change in a future
session any other questions I don't see
any so um we will move right along we've
got four whoops four P cards left
here I'd like to call Keen mang Wang to
to
you morning members of the committee my
name is Keen Ming Wong I'm the tax
policy councel at the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue um the department
does not have a position on this bill
however uh just wanted to highlight a
potential concern that the department
has on the the language on the um the
licensing requirements of the bill um
here during all the previous discussions
before me I believe that the the
licensing requirements that's uh in
intended in this bill is specifically
reference to the homestate food
operations license um there is a license
uh for M and rooms tax license where uh
operators of meals of taxable meals in
New Hampshire are required to obtain a
uh M&R license before commencing the
operations so the concern that the Dr
has is the uh the language on lines 24
and 25 page one of the bill um and it
says that the production and sale of
homestate food products in accordance
with this subdivision are exempt from
all licensing permitting inspection
packaging and labeling laws in this
state um this is a the the concern is
that all licensing would also potenti uh
in this state would Encompass the M&R
license
uh looking back to the previous version
well not the previous version but the
current version of the uh RSA 143 d a
um and
uh colon 12 um the the current language
on that exemption uh is exempt from lure
and departmental inspection under this
subdivision so the uh the language in
the current statute is more limiting to
the current
subdivision of home of home state food
licensing versus the uh proposed
language which expands it to all
licensing um in this state that is um
that's just our concerns that we want to
highlight to the committee for
consideration okay thank you any
questions from the committee thank you
you um I would like to call
last
yes well good morning committee members
and thank you for having me for the
record I'm representative Deborah Elward
I represent marac District 5 that's uh
Andover danburry Hill Salsbury and
Webster I'm here in support
representative kulan's
bill um I'm the prime sponsor of a
similar bill that you're going to hear
this
afternoon um I find it ironic the two
reps who didn't know each other uh came
up with such similar bills I think it
shows um a
need uh for food Freedom uh in this
session
and and I really applaud his efforts we
both uh got assistance from The
Institute of
justice and we'll be providing a chart
that will compare the two bills for your
work session if you don't already have
it and I uh look forward to speaking
more on this subject this
afternoon
however
um regarding what um the department
stated about opening a Gateway they're
reluctant to open a
Gateway uh that Gateway has been open
for a very long time involving
nonprofits that have been serving this
food potentially hazardous food to
thousands of members of the public
annually through their
Community dinners Church pot lucks bake
sales you name it and I have provided
photographic evidence of such um type of
activity where it was buil as homemade
and delicious for a chicken pie
supper
and as far as separating the homade food
producer from the consumer the law
currently allows for sales at retail
food
stores it should be no different from a
restaurant or a uh any other type of
venue uh because it's been in law
currently and as far as internet
sales the bill both bills go into uh
where the food can has to be maintained
at uh appropriate temperature and it can
only be transported for two hours so I
think that limits where you can send
food whether it's you know you know
shelf stable or potentially
hazardous and so that's my only comments
for right
now okay thank you any
questions seeing
none we'll hear from you later thank you
justice and then I have another pink
card somebody submitted but there's no
name on
is
okay you you need one okay go ahead I'm
sorry thank you madam chair and members
of the committee I appreciate the
opportunity to testify today in support
of this bill and we also support
representative ills bill that's going to
be heard later today my name is Megan
Forbes I'm a senior legislative council
at The Institute for justice we're a
nonprofit organization that has helped
Homestead um food producers also called
commonly Cottage food producers across
the country reform restrictive laws that
prevent them from earning a living and
we support these bills because they
expand economic Liberty and
opportunities for Homestead food
producers and consumers and they do so
in a way that's proven to be safe at The
Institute for justice we've studied the
effect of Homestead food businesses on
local economies and communities and
researched food safety we've consulted
experts we've reviewed CDC data and
followed up with health departments and
states that have expanded their
Homestead food laws in ways that are
comparable to the approaches that both
of these bills take our research
confirms that Homestead food is
inherently safe for producers and
consumers we've also found that
Homestead food businesses create
important opportunities for
entrepreneurship they help support
families and they help bolster local
economies seven states now California
Iowa Montana North Dakota Oklahoma Utah
and Wyoming have enacted similar laws to
support the local production of homemade
food including allowing the sale of
perishable food um also called
potentially has ardous food notably in
these states there's not been one
confirmed case of food born illness
Wyoming has the oldest law it's been
around for almost nine years now and
there are no cases again of foodborn
illness related to the sale of cottage
food in Wyoming that we've
confirmed Wyoming's laws receive
National recognition for safely
increasing access to local food and
opportunity um the these bills bring
much needed reform to the state's
Homestead food producers we commend the
committee for all of the work that
you've done over the last few years to
expand Homestead food but there's a lot
of room for improvement still um
compared to what other states across the
country are now doing um under both
bills homemade food must be accurately
labeled with all ingredients consumers
must also be made aware that the food
was prepared in a home kitchen that's
not regulated consumers have all the
information that they need to make
informed decisions about whether to
purchase and consume the food um for
these reasons we encourage the committee
to support the production and sale of
Homestead food and um this bill and also
the bill that's going to be heard later
this afternoon thank you very much and
I'm happy to answer any questions that
you may have sure I have a question if
you have submitted electronic testimony
to the committee or do you have
electronic
testimony so that we can give it to the
clerk Madam chair yes ma'am I I did
submit um electronic testimony this
morning okay thank you did you receive
that no I I don't believe I have either
oh I'd be happy to follow up and make
sure that it was we love to have your
written testimony um logged
in okay uh any questions from the
committee representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair and thank you for your
testimony What would label seems like
there's a lot of things that have to be
on these labels so what would a label
look like that says it's prepared in a
home kitchen the label includes the
ingredients of the food and the common
name that consumers would recognize it
as um it also by including the
ingredients includes the any potential
allergens so consumers would be able to
see if there were allergens and then it
includes a disclaimer on the label that
um says that the food was prepared shed
in a home kitchen that's not subject to
regulation or that's not licensed and
the disclaimer that's required and it
has to be word for word is in the bill
um so so the language would be in the
law that the producer would have to
follow I see thank you any other
questions representative
Duty um yes uh thank you uh do you have
a range of Revenue that um somebody who
produces food in their home
uh would make in a year like the lowest
to the
highest it it's difficult to to give a
range I'll say that most often what we
see is that these are very small scale
food operations we have surveyed Cottage
food producers um Homestead food
producers across the country and we
found that many are are not making a lot
of food um they're earning a few
thousand dollar extra but it's making a
big difference for their families but
occasionally we do see Homestead food
producers that are able to grow their
businesses and often times they get to a
point where being in their home doesn't
make sense anymore and then they want to
take that step to become a commercially
licensed business and have all the
advantages that a commercial business
has um so in a way these laws also
create a stepping stone for people to be
able to use the homestead law to be able
to get to that next step followup yep
so are you saying that the existing law
would prevent them from doing this and
this law is needed so that they could
support their families
better representative yes I think this
law would greatly help people be able to
better support their families be able to
better um build their businesses the the
greatest obstacle that we see in this
space for food entrepreneurs is that the
cost of building a commercial um kitchen
is quite expensive um there there's lots
of expensive equipment requirements um
and and for the small scale production
of food it can be very difficult to
overcome those costs um as the
department mentioned earlier there is
the option to rent commercial kitchen
space um but doing so is not easy uh
it's often not costeff effective either
a commercial kitchen space is usually
available to be rented a lot of times
when commercial kitchen
um are not operating so they're not
convenient times for people to be able
to actually um use them and and again
it's another costly
option representative Murray thank you
madam chair um and thank you for taking
my question so one of my questions is I
guess you just mentioned commercial
kitchen spaces but then wouldn't that
have already transcended being a a
homestead or a cottage purveyor if
you're looking into commercial kitchen
space um that sort of is the next step
like others have mentioned and so you're
already moving into a
commercial outfit at that point if
you're seeking license or seeking to use
those um kitchens to produce more food
in the at those quantities to sell those
amounts of food is that what you're
repres yes representative it would be um
when you're looking to expand your
production there's no matter what
there's only so much food that a person
can make in their home kitchen um so it
what we see is people want to expand and
when they do they get to a point where
they want to open up commercial kitchen
space to do so um once their business
becomes profitable enough where they can
get to that point um but it the nice
thing is that it it doesn't require a
person to go thousands of dollars into
debt before they start out which is a
lot of times why we see people in in
this industry failing when they're
starting because the startup cost are so
high um to to to sell
food represent H Haskins thank you madam
chair and again thank you for um taking
my question I'm intrigued about this
idea of um renting commercial space and
I'd be happy to see any
information that you or others may have
about how often this is happening in new
hampire what do the costs look like I
think that information would be useful
if you could provide it sure we'd be
happy to look into that and give you
that information specific to New
Hampshire thank you thank you I don't
see any other hands up for uh for you
miss Ford so thank you very much for
your uh your testimony and I have a a
pink card for
Nim I'm sorry what you'll have to give
sure uh good morning I didn't plan on
speaking today so you have to excuse me
I'm trying to do this on the Fly um my
name is nma goala I own a commercial uh
commercial kitchen sorry commercial
kitchen and food business incubator in
Dair New Hampshire before you continue
please can you please um I'm goingon to
need you to spill out your entire name
so after you're done would you come up
and take care of that absolutely
absolutely um
we've been in business for about 11
years um um April makes it 11 years we
are a commercial kitchen and a business
incubator the reason I started the
business is because I like
entrepreneurship and I like food and uh
11 years ago I thought of this idea and
I did some research and we have a
thriving business um at last count we
have probably
about 45 licenses that have gone through
our kitchen a lot of of them have uh
opened up their own businesses and moved
on from our space but what we do is we
work with serious businesses we don't do
hobbyist uh these are food food areas
that that um that cover the gamut from
everything from uh um um Caterers to um
to chocolate makers to SAU makers spice
makers whatever they' like to do we
don't do a lot uh with uh with Meats
because we're not a USDA certified space
but apart from that any company in the
New Hampshire that or or Massachusetts
that want to start a food business we
help them do that we are a certified we
are inspected by the town of dairy
health inspector we are uh inspected by
the FDA they come to do inspections on a
regular basis and we've had USDA
inspectors in the kitchen as well we
maintain a very very clean very sanitary
um kitchen and we have all the equipment
that someone would need to open their
business so we have commercial
Restaurant St size um um stoves and
ovens um mixers blenders everything is
clean and sanitized for every user to um
to start their production um we don't
encourage any type of chemicals in our
kitchen all our grease straps are
outside the kitchen as well so there's
no contam there's no possibility for
contamination um
um what else um we have our inspect our
equipment inspected and and and um and
maintained on a regular basis and we
meet All State Fire and health
codes and it's a place for for for
businesses to incubate we work with
companies that want to expand out so
after a couple of years I usually
encourage them to move on um especially
when they start to get larger than we
can support we I try to find places for
them to move into other locations
facilities on their own because we are
just an incubator we don't uh we can't
support large businesses we can support
a couple of people doing a few things
and grow their business um but once they
start to find employees and they want
more more production space more storage
space we will we're not able to sorry
we're not able to support them because
we are an incubator for small startups
and may I ask what how much do you
charge charge for that service we have a
um a different levels actually of
pricing we expect because we don't do
Hobbies we want to do serious businesses
one of our requirements is we we ask
people to be in the kitchen when they
start up for about 12 hours a month and
we charge $25 an hour for full use of
the kitchen once they start to increase
their production hours we lower the
rates so our lowest rate is $20 an hour
and that's for people are in the kitchen
for about 32 hours a month we but we
have people work at our kitchen for 90
hours 120 hours it depends on on their
production and we have a lower rate
based on that okay thank you
representative
Bixby so would you see this bill as uh
potentially creating a pathway for
people who might eventually want to take
advantage of your kitchen or would you
see this bill as being problematic
because it circumvents the need for a
commercial kitchen
um the the the the the person who was
here before um was saying you know that
you can start a small business and in
your home and then when you are get to a
certain size you won't be able to uh
produce at home so you'll have to move
into a commercial kitchen um we don't
have
um as many issues
with um with competing with with home
kitchens because there're only certain
amount of products at the moment that
you can make it home even non-hazardous
products come to our kitchen because the
space the services that we provide for
them to grow um we do we help them with
labels and packaging and we I hold their
hand pretty much right to the start of
process so what we offer in our kitchen
um
for our
businesses we're not going to it's not
going to be this bill is not going to be
a threat to us because we work we work
with serious businesses not those who
would just want to see what's out there
and and you know do a hobby type of of
of of an Endeavor um I don't I mean I'm
I'm pretty sure this business this will
affect our business in some way um but
there we get so many inquiries on a
regular regular basis I'm not sure how
this is going to affect our business in
the long run um because we do offer a
lot more services than a home kitchen
can however I would definitely say that
this would not be good for the the food
the local food market or the local food
industry as such it it it it introduces
an element of
Sanitation and
um and
foodborn illnesses that I would not like
to see permeate this this this little
market of ours it's not going to
be beneficial for New Hampshire local
food markets to encourage production in
an unsafe
environment representative Howard thank
you madam chair um do you have more than
one vendor in your kitchen at a time so
it's divided up and and they work side
by side yes we we have I built the
kitchen I designed it to allow up to
eight businesses to to produce at the
same time um however we've never hit
that spot because most of our businesses
tend to be uh they're not professionals
and they work out of their home kitchens
they like a little more Elbow Room so
I've limited to about five and since Co
it's just been three and I try to keep
it to three sometimes we have four but
not more than that each person gets a
couple of tables they've got a lot more
space we're open 24/7 so anyone can come
in at any time and um it works out well
because I I I schedule everything so I
know exactly what who does what and what
space they need and what equipment they
need so I make it as convenient and as
easy for them to produce in a very clean
safe environment that's one of my major
goals representative kto thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question what is the name of your
business please it's called creative
Chef kitchens and it's in Dairy New
Hampshire okay thank you I see no other
questions from the committee so thank
you for your testimony thank you and
with all this talk of food it's
lunchtime I'm
hungry so I uh going to uh there was no
uh people signing up on the blue sheet
but online the testimonies were 14
people in
support and eight people in
opposition and with that I'm going to
close uh hb6 uh
1565 we will adjourn for lunch and be
back here at 1:00 for
for another
again
good afternoon
everyone excuse me welcome back to
environment agriculture committee and um
I am going to open up the uh hearing
this afternoon for HB
1685 redefining Homestead food
as Artisan Foods creating an artisan
food operations exemption
establishing uh establishing Artisan
food product sales venues and allowing
the production and sale of artisan food
products requiring
refrigeration and to introduce this
bill this afternoon I invite
representative Deborah
Elward to come and speak with us again
back and will you be speaking on the
bill or the amendment to the bill Madam
chair I'm not sure how that works the
reason I had to do an amendment was in
the final hour before sign off deadline
on the
lsrs a group of representatives were
only given four day I was only given
four days so I was not given the luxury
of a
redraft and that how the amendment came
about so how does that work I would like
to well I guess if you um present the
the uh premise of your bill and um the
amendment which purports to support that
or and or what the amendment does to fix
the original bill I think that covers it
oh perfect thank you very much and good
afternoon am I correct in that
representative Bixby yeah
okay yeah so essentially
essentially the you know your intent was
is presumably pretty much the same and
it's just details that are different
that differ so uh if you first go over
your intent and then uh and then just
assume that uh the amendment covers the
details in the amendment are the details
we should pay attention to that should
take care of it perfect thank you very
much so again for the record I'm
representative Deborah Elward and I
represent the inhabitants of the towns
of Andover Danberry Hills Salsbury and
Webster I have the greatest privilege of
presenting to you house bill
1685 which amends the laws governing
homemade
foods when I think of New Hampshire I
think of a warm fire a homemade Yankee
pot roast complete with bra locally
raised vegetables and baked beans and
ham bread with lots of butter and A
clastic Boston cream pie for d dessert I
think of the great tradition of New
England cooking the communal sharing of
hearty comforting moods meals and the
fellowship that occurs in just about
every town across the state at community
and church dinners that serve homemade
foods to thousands of granite Staters
annually and without
regulation but I also think about and
question how sharing the Bounty of our
state and talented home Cooks are held
back by our very own laws that
illogically prevent the sale of the very
same foods to those who want to
conveniently buy wholesome n nutritious
Foods locally and as a method of
deriving
income honorable committee members we
have a chance to change all that an
opportunity to make hungry people happy
and add the great state of New Hampshire
to a growing list list of states
engaging in what is called the food
Freedom
Movement but more importantly is seizing
this incredible opportunity to make the
laws fair and
reasonable this bill is about food fun
families free enterprise and free
markets in essence everything for which
the great state of New Hampshire stands
for so here's what 1685 does it would
support fames by giving them more
freedom to cook and share their
carefully crafted foods with informed
and willing consumers to derive or
perhaps supplement their
incomes in particular it would be a boom
to those who might not be able to work
fulltime such as stay-at-home moms and
caregivers and give aspiring food
entrepreneurs a chance to start small in
their home test the market and build
their business
the bill would Empower consumers by
giving people more choices particularly
in rural areas where Specialty Foods and
healthy meals while in demand can be
scarce house bille 1685 would be safe
and transparent with required labeling
and other food safety protocols
implemented at every step in the
process and of course House Bill 1685
removes restrictions and prohibition
that are substantiated as
unnecessary such as the ban on producing
non shelf stable products in residential
kitchens without a license because there
is indisputable clear and convincing
evidence that homemade foods are
inherently
safe we know this works because for
decades New Hampshire has allowed non
shelf stable foods to be produced in
residential kitchens which are then
served to thousands of people Statewide
annually by nonprofits and
municipalities hosting Food Service
events that are exempt from lure in
other words there's a double standard
that's being applied to homeade food
producers this bill includes necessary
definitions that support the new
regulatory scheme which provides a
plethora of New Economic opportuni I
ities that do not exist under current
law but they're already in
place given the reality of the
marketplace this bill does not limit
Regulators ability to enforce the laws
but actually it makes Regulators a
partner in the
process that through Ru making will
twice annually Enlighten the populace
about the laws and rules governing what
I term Artisan food products through
media
attention which will further assist in
the process by creating protocols for
non- shelf stable foods which will
ensure Optimum
compliance I would like to take a
second to read from Wyoming's 2023
Senate Bill
51 the ACT is known as the food Freedom
Act section three legislative findings
this legislator finds the following
a there is a great interest in small
scale homebased food businesses in this
state but current law restricts
entrepreneurs ability to establish and
grow such
businesses B expanding the freedom of
entrepreneurs to operate home-based food
businesses will provide numerous
benefits including the opportunity for
self-employment
and to earn an honest living through the
work that affords flexibility creativity
and financial
Awards
rewards C consumers desire food produced
by such
entrepreneurs D expanding the freedom of
consumers to procure food from homebased
food businesses will provide many
benefits including consumers in urban
and rural areas in the state gaining
access to a greater variety of food
options especially fresh food produced
on a small local
scale C or
E evidence from other states show that
homebased food businesses are safe and
finally F allowing the production sale
and consumption of a greater variety of
homemade foods respects individuals
personal Liberty including economic
Liberty individuals should be free to
produce procure and consume the homemade
choice so given the extent to which this
bill goes to accomplish these goals
including the amendment that makes the
underlying bills language
whole they include Corrections and
additions that should have been in a
second draft I'm respectfully requesting
that members carefully excuse me
consider the irrefutable facts and move
House Bill 1685 with Amendment forward
to ensure a positive impact on the
purveyors of homemade food and consumers
who crave their
offerings I have a lot of research here
too much to go into uh during this
hearing but I'd be willing to let the
committee researcher peruse it if it
would help with the work session uh
upcoming I want to thank you for your
bill my bill is
um different and more indepth than House
Bill
1565 for two years I I immersed myself
into the homemade food industry I had
been a licensed kitchen back in 20 8
you'll read this in my testimony and I
don't want to be
redundant and I made Gourmet
brownies State Fair awardwinning
brownies and I took them to farmers
markets I vended them wherever I could
but I'm a letter of the law kind of
gal I've been a regulated licensed
professional almost all my
life
and I read that I was only a able to
sell at retail food stores farmers
markets from a farm stand that I didn't
own I don't have a Farm
Stand and um Farmers Market
retails and farmers
markets so when I had this opportunity
to um delve into the
laws because I found the rules extremely
convoluted and confusing on one hand
you're being you can make jam and jelly
but you have to undergo process review
at the University of Maine for example
it's $140 per
recipe I have one constituent who makes
like 20 different jams and jellies she's
been selling them for
years what does that tell me it tells me
and and she has not undergone process
review so it tells me that her food is
safe it's a low-risk f food and that it
would cost her close to three grand if
she complied with the process review
requirement um I interviewed vendors
Market
managers uh people who wanted to get
into the business but felt very
intimidated or felt restricted or
prohibited then I was Finding
non-compliance everywhere in the
marketplace because banana
bread is a low acid food
that actually requires State lab testing
for water activity in pH
levels but everywhere I went I seeing
banana bread I was seeing labeling uh
Omission
uh people who just when I asked them I
said are you aware of RSA
143a and they would either deny it or
you could see that they knew about it
but they claimed they didn't and so
we've had a type of Black Market if you
will of these
Foods uh and I made record requests of
DHHS and they couldn't produce any
records over the past twoe period of
food born illnesses being traced back
to food produced in uh a
homestead
capacity then I kept looking at the
definition
of occasional Food Service
event and that's where
nonprofits
schools are exempt from Food Service
lure that is what we're talking about
sale holiday events national uh old home
days where food is made in residential
kitchens taken to a Comm Community
dinner
and serve to people they're potentially
hazardous we're talking you know chicken
turkey ham uh barbecue cream pies
pumpkin pies salads every type of
homemade food you can think
of yet the department came back and was
unre could not be responsive to a
request for records that
these Food Service events were causing
foodborn
illness so it's this really AA gotcha
moment this is a double standard how can
you possibly not regulate potentially
hazardous foods here that serve to the
public just because it's a nonprofit or
a
school and yet the same woman making the
pie for this nonprofit event can't turn
around and sell it for
income so that's when I contacted the
Institute of Justice because we ra
as a C+ for food Freedom uh based on the
institute's research and I said what's
it going to take to bring this up to an
A and so they helped Mr uh rep kulan and
myself with the
language but I wanted to see it very
clear um that there were food safety
protocols not buried in administrative
rules I wanted to see it in the law that
was easy to
comprehend that's not to say that
through Ru making the department won't
have a
hand in informing consumers how to
safely process and handle low acid foods
dairy so some of the differences first
of all is change Ching the the name of
this industry to Artisan food
operations and I say this because the
word Homestead skews in favor of farmers
not all homemade food operators are are
homesteading which is living a lifestyle
of
self-sufficiency and quite frankly
that's what these people want to be
called take the Canan farmers and
Artisan Market
so I outlined uh ad nauseum the
definition of
artisan and it being uh about
handcrafting a
good um
because I feel it will uplifted industry
everyone it's a relatable descriptive
term and somehow I just can't relate the
word Homestead to an elegantly decorated
special occasion cake dainty Petty
fors uh and I think we need to make it
more General to what this industry
really is so I'm I'm introducing the
term Artisan in place of
Homestead I attacked the definitions in
this
law
because it seemed like the word
establishment and event were
interchangeable throughout it was very
confusing so I wanted to make it clear
that you have licensed establishments
and then you have Artisan food
operations you have occasional Food
Service
functions um and temporary sales and uh
sales events and
venues and I went into great
detail to make it so you could sell
basically anywhere and everywhere
following the
same format as as current law now much
to my chagrin talking with uh Miss
Colleen Smith from HHS this morning
about um a woman debuting her business
that was featured in a local newspaper
at a craft
fair and I'm looking at retail food
store Farm Stand farmers market and from
your residence and I don't see craft
fair in there at all and so this morning
I was told that they don't
prohibit Foods being sold at a craft
fair well does that mean I can sell it
at a at a non food retail store does it
mean I can sell at a local event that's
not a farmers's market well apparently
so
so these four what I call authorized
places um I believe has been a detriment
to people entering into the
industry a retail food stor such as a
major grocery store will take homemade
foods but you have to keep up with the
demand and the
average residential kitchen can't can't
keep up with that kind of
demand farmers markets let's face
it um in the farmer Market directory for
2023 published by the Department of
Agriculture there's only 25 listings
there's 204
municipalities that means one farmer's
market for every eight towns not only
does going to a farmers's market take
you away from your local customer
base uh but it not all farmers markets
will take on all homemade food producers
it's not a public market it's it's not a
publicly operated Market it's it's
operated by private
Enterprise and again not everybody owns
a farm stand so I created the definition
of residential roadside
stand in rural areas everything is sold
roadside and I've seen um
unenclosed uh Farm
stands uh
roadside and I don't see any difference
in putting an honor System
cart at the end of my road and selling
my homemade breads every day uh so I
went ahead and and made that a
definition um I
place and then there is the temporary
food sales event or venue which means a
temporary event or series of events or
venues that are open to the public by
whatever name
advertise where food including Artisan
food products are sold to
Consumers this is because like I said
you can have the church fair old home
days even voting day is where food is is
sold you go into town hall and there's
this banquet table full of food that's
being
vended um so there's no way to list all
of them and Farmers Market would fall
under temporary food sales eventor
venue we included third-party
vendor um where I can
ask my friend down the road who who owns
a a gift shop uh if she'd like to sell
my
product
um we even included the ability to sell
uh from a mobile food unit if you're
exclusively selling Artisan
Foods so then I changed occasional Food
function just to differentiate between
these different categories now if what
dhh says is true none of these
definitions are NE
necessary just take it all out and say
you can sell wherever you want whenever
you
want but um not knowing that at the time
we created the the function which would
even allow private chefs and Caterers to
make meals in their home because right
now the only way they are exempt or
private Chef is exempt from lure is
where they make the food they make the
food in their client's residence they're
not allowed to prep it at
home and this would allow that to happen
as long as they maintain temperature
control in transporting it to their
client's
location
um so then it was food safety
important that it be in law rather than
in
Rule and so an artisan food product
means all food
including but not limited to soft
beverages low acid acidified and
fermented food that's produced by an
artisan food operation only within the
home kitchen of a person's primary
residence if canned canned using the
method so this is um important because
there's water bath canning there's
pressure canning and depending on the
type of food depends on which method you
use for food
safety um we also included a disclaimer
that uh this section shall not absolve a
producer from
liability this allows delivery by a
third-party
carrier it allows uh telephone internet
sales and again
in
section um a12 Roman 3
C if potentially hazardous Artisan
products are transported before final
delivery to the consumer or thirdparty
vendor the part the food shall be
maintained at an appropriate temperature
during transport cannot be transported
more than once and cannot be transported
for longer than two hours and after
reaching its final destination shall be
maintained at an appropriate temperature
at all times
thereafter so if you want to put a
display refrigerated display case in a
retail store that features your
cheesecake this would
apply uh you certainly wouldn't want to
be transporting
cheesecake
um selling it to California for
example so then I took on the word uh on
sampling and through throughout the
amendment you'll see the word sampled
sampled sampled because in the um
administrative rule no excuse me publish
guidance by
UNH says that you can't sample unless
you cut whatever it is into bread into
pieces and put it into a plastic cup
with a cap and I'm sorry but Sam's Club
doesn't even do that they lay it out on
on a
napkin and I think that um single serves
spoons for jellies on a cracker that's
just widely accepted method of
sampling uh if I had potentially had if
I had award-winning CH chili that I was
selling uh at in an
event i' probably use an inverter bring
my crock pot with the hot chili in it
and I'd have it in Deli containers in a
in a cooler with ice and so I sent a
photo array uh that gives an example of
a a
agricultural
vendor who uh does this events so if
they can do it if they can sell
potentially hazardous food at events why
producer so then came the the statements
on the
labels that if it's low acid acidified
or fermented it should be clearly
labeled uh with refrigerate after
opening but if it requires maintaining
time and temperature control for
safety I think I invented this this
statement I've never seen it in the
marketplace in my life but it would say
consume immediately or refrigerate after
purchase after purchase eat it now or
get it home into a refrigerator that
tells you it's
perishable it should be on
every hamburger container that you don't
leave it in the back seat for eight
hours and eat it so I was really proud
of
that um and I I am the former manager of
our family bakery we had a wholesale
retail bakery in northern
Virginia
um and so I've been in the food business
on and off throughout my
life um it
allows offering um for sale out of bulk
um a cake you can have it in a pan and
you can
serve on a napkin and people can consume
it where they
are
um you must have a placard that's
displayed at the point of sale if you're
not going to do a
label
and then you also have to have
um your information your ingredients Etc
uh on on your
website and if you sell by telephone or
custom order you have to orally disclose
allergens
ingredients uh fact that it's made in a
in a residential unlicensed kitchen as
well
now you'll see that that there's a
statement may contain allergens rather
allergens the average homemade food
producer doesn't necessarily know there
are nine major
allergens and there is a risk of
cross-contamination if you're making
peanut butter cookies in the same
kitchen with your chocolate
chip you want people the you want people
to know that chocolate chip cookie you
know may may have been cross
contaminated with peanut butter not to
serve it to children or if you have a
food allergy in other words be very
careful before you buy a homemade food
look at the
ingredients um one homemade producer put
lactose as an
allergen and for the life of me I
couldn't understand why uh lactose is a
sugar that comes from milk
um but it's not listed by the government
as a major
allergen and she also put oatmeal as an
allergen and I don't see that oatmeal is
listed as an allergen so I I don't want
to leave it to
um the homemade food producer to know
what these major allergens are and I
think all products coming out of a home
kitchen should say make contain
allergens also if the product contains
alcohol it has to be produced in
accordance with RSA 175 colon
5-a which says you uh has certain
restrictions uh the product can you have
to get the alcohol from a New Hampshire
liquor store it cannot contain more than
6% alcohol by
volume and you can't serve it to
children people under 20 21 if the
temperature is 61 or something like
that it's it's kind of strange but I
thought it was important to reference
because in the record request I got back
from
HHS one of the complaints concerned a
product that contained alcohol so I
thought it was
important
um local governments shall not regulate
artisan food operations in a manner that
is more restrictive than required by
state or federal law so we do have the
self- inspecting cities
um we have municipalities that issue
permits
and we are are opposed to these
governments uh making
up restrictive rules that are not
necessary then I've asked the department
to um publish links to all the
applicable laws and rules and remove
broken links and outdated information
that is just permeated all over the
Internet it still has the sales
still talks about this process
review uh on one hand it says yes you
can make jams and jellies over here but
no it has that you have to have process
review and then you might need a
homestead food license and I just can't
make hner tale of the published guidance
that's out there and then finally under
the certified food protection
manager um Homestead food operations are
currently exempt and it just changed the
the word to Artisan food operation and
under ruem it gives the
department um again the ability to
create rules regarding the safe
processing handling of low acid foods
dairy product meat meat food products
and byproducts poultry and poultry food
products and
byproducts I borrowed all that language
from rep kulan's
Bill meaning no disrespect I was trying
to make house bills
1685 um
include all the different language from
both bills so with that I'll I'll take
any
questions thank you and um at this time
I would like I would like um
representative brard and representative
sofikitis to take their
seats prior to us asking any
questions do we have questions from the
committee representative um kraton
sorry hey thank you so much for your
detailed research and and
testimony uh having looked at the other
Bill and been part of the discussion
this
morning it seems to me we have two
pretty
much similar bills wh which one in your
opinion would be more applicable and
1565 well on one hand if what HHH says
is true
that you can sell homemade shelf stable
homemade foods anywhere and everywhere
all
what representative kulan bill says in
addition to the poultry meat dairy
products and I I'm good with that
anything that that allows uh food
Freedom I'm good with that
but interviewing people who are confused
by the
law I feel they need a little bit more
information a little bit more step
bystep uh more
thorough
information because it's going to be
peer pressure it's going to be event
managers it's going to be retail food
stores that are looking to have those
products comply with the
law
and I really think I combined
both uh bills because Institute of
Justice provided much of the language in
both bills but I went further to be more
clear because to me that 1565 is to me
vague it says licensed restaurants and
grocery stores
and so one thinks well they they said
license you know restaurants and grocery
stores is that the only place I can sell
so I know I I'm a regulatory um nut I I
served on our uh Advisory Board in
Virginia I was appointed to a four-year
term I helped
promulgate rules and laws relative to
the private investigator industry so
so I like it to be clear and concise and
I think that mine is thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and thanks for taking my question
on page two of your amendments where
you're referring starting at lines um
three through
eight um can you explain to me how the
language that you're proposing versus
the federal language under the uh Bill
Emerson Good Samaritan act may or may
not I did I missed
that can you explain to me how the
language you are proposing under lines
three through eight on page two may or
may not conflict with the bill Emerson
Goods meritan
act I I got to the word conflict I
couldn't hear you ma'am representative I
couldn't hear do I need to turn up my
microphone after um maybe I don't know
or speak closer to the mic sure I was
just asking how um is that
better how the language that you
proposed in those lines may or may not
conflict with the federal Bill Emerson
Good Samaritan act I I'm unfamiliar with
that
bill okay thank
you could you repeat the name of that
bill or act it's the bill Emerson Good
Samaritan
act do you know when that was adopted at
all I can go back and look as early as
1996 I think and then it may even go
back further than that but it is still
Fally recognized okay thank
committee okay thank you for that
lengthy and thorough introduction going
um bit by bit through this I appreciate
you pointing out important as aspects of
this bill um next I would like to
call Colleen Smith and Katrina Hansen
speak sorry good afternoon thank you
madam chair and members of the committee
for the record my name is Colleen Smith
um with the Department of Health and
Human Services the administrator for the
food protection section and I'm joined
Again by Katrina Hansen who is our chief
of infectious disease surveillance with
the department and she would be happy to
answer any questions related to foodborn
illness um before before you continue um
just interest interested to know if you
were familiar with the amendment that
representative Elward presented I was re
I did receive a copy of the amendment um
after presentation of the last bill so I
I had an opportunity to per peruse it
okay thank you thank you so I won't
repeat um many of our talking points
that we used in previous testim
testimony for 1565 I did just want to
highlight to the committee um the
definition of a temporary event so that
that is or an occasional Food Service
event those are not um inspected or
licensed in the state's jurisdiction but
I do want to recognize that many of the
self- inspecting cities and towns they
do do a temporary permit or an
occasional permit so some of those Food
Services um are still under some
inspection so so just wanted to make
sure the committee was aware of that and
that if this legislation were to pass
they those communities wouldn't be
allowed to regulate those events under a
temporary
permit the bill as written will make
regular
very very difficult while it does allow
the department to do Ru making and to um
have a fine with non-compliance it will
be it's it's already very difficult for
us to enforce the standards for existing
Homestead regulations because many of
these products are offered direct from
the home or at farmers markets or um
venues that we typically don't regulate
um as has been mentioned in previous
testimony we do receive consumer
complaints and we do react to those but
it is of often difficult to make do
enforcement we have no licensing ability
of those we don't we can't hold a
license back be for non-compliance it's
very very difficult we're really relying
on um the producer to uh act in
accordance with the law on their own
accord it I I won't I you know once
homestad licensing has was removed it
does make our enforcement very very
difficult so I just wanted to highlight
that to the committee and this to us
would um make a a a more risky situation
by allowing again higher risk foods that
don't that do require refrigeration for
safety or canned foods that have a
higher risk at making someone sick if
done if done um produced in a manner uh
in a an unsafe manner um certainly there
is an obligation when providing food to
the public to ensure it's safe we do ask
that um Homestead operations or any
operation that is not using a
standardized recipe that it's in their
best interest to conduct a process
review this is an assurance from a that
this product and their process has been
reviewed by a food safety professional
to give them good advice this again the
consequences of improperly processing
especially in acidified or low acid food
could be deadly and it it really um
these making food for the public is is
um should have some food safety
responsibility that comes with that our
work is preventative we are instilling
regulations in place to prevent food
born illness and this legislation of
passed would put us uh it would really
make that very very difficult for us to
to enforce and I'm happy to take any
so
um Community Food food banks where they
have meals for the
community uh people who are
um who are looking for you know meals
that
are are those uh kitchens are those
Community uh food kitchens regulated and
licensed so by Statute soup kitchens are
exempt from our food licensing and
inspection we have we do try to provide
best guidance and on on good safe
practices but it's it's not enforceable
also I want to mention just UNH
extension they do a a free food safety
training for anyone that's working in a
in a uh food pantry or similar
establishment so seeing as these um food
kitchens soup kitchens are
providing
possibly you know uh whatever the
language is for
for possibly dangerous foods uh to a
great number of people on a daily basis
how is that different from say another
person wanting to offer their their uh
culinary foods to uh to the public so
what I can offer is that I wouldn't say
that that's a it's a
risk-free situation I think there is a
Gap there that there isn't oversight on
these particular venues but as I
mentioned by Statute they're exempt from
our license and inspection do you
believe they should be inspected I
believe that they should H I believe
that they should have the best
information available from food practice
from food safety practices these
situations can be a little they might
not fit in the box of the same box
regulatory box as our normal retail
stores and or restaurants and that they
might not have a consistent staff but
I'm sure that um there there always
could be benefit from education
opportunities and you just to make sure
refrigerators are working correctly um
it it there is a there's a lot of
difficulty around that I think that's an
issue that um merits further exploration
for sure so do you also uh require
licensing for like senior centers who
have uh lunches provided that they they
offer lunches so senior meal sites they
do fall under our license well they do
okay all right thank you any other
questions representative
Murray um thank you madam chair um if
you could take a look with me you have
the
amendment yeah uh before you okay so on
the first page line uh 26 and I'm I'm
just wanting to make sure I'm
interpreting there's a strike through on
the word event and I wasn't clear if
that was referring to like a single
function or if this meant like an
extreme you know flooding or weather
type of event where there would be
because it's under imminent health
hazard so I was curious to
know how
that word is interpreted there is that
is that around a natural disaster or is
it more like
a so I we we um would prefer that that
term event stay in place because an
event in and up itself could create a
eminent health hazard you overcrowding
and and the restrooms are no longer
functional and you have sewage backup an
event could contribute to a eminent
health
hazard represent kulon thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm curious if you have any
evidence that connects food born illness
with homestead food products in New
Hampshire sure thank you for your
question so as I mentioned on our uh the
previous testimony is sometimes it's
very challenging to directly link food
items consumed to a respective illness
just by the nature of the time period it
can take from someone to acquire and eat
that food it can take three to five days
for some depending on the bacteria that
you're looking at um to be ill but it
could also be very quick if it's a toxin
um so usually people will be sick and
then it will take a period of time
before they even seek health care so it
can be a week or two weeks Rec call bias
or being able to remember what you ate
at that time is very challenging we do
foodborn interviews so if we do get a
case that comes in we investigate and we
we interview individuals who are ill or
a medical proxy so for example if it's a
parent of a child um and we do those
interviews and we collect a food history
depending on what we think the par
particular illness may be so we can try
to identify or pinpoint that item
however if it's been two weeks or a week
after their illness it is very hard for
us to acquire specimens from from Human
specimens so St specimens to be able to
then also link that directly to a
particular food item typically food
items are discarded within a certain
period of time that said um we have not
identified very many Link Link directly
to Homestead foods but I think that's
also because most of the items right now
that are available that can be SED by
Homestead foods are lower risk whereas
this bill proposes Homestead foods that
may be higher risk as meats and cheeses
um and other prepared foods that have
higher risk across contain and are
directly or more directly linked to
outbreaks when we do see them um I hope
that answered your question follow up
follow up uh that sounds like a no to me
am I hearing you correctly no we don't
have any over the last two years when we
looked compared to Homestead Foods we
did not see any directly linked but just
because you don't see the data doesn't
mean that they're not there we also do
know that there's vast Under reporting
of anic illness because most people
don't seek medical care to be able to
really confirm ideology if they have an
anic illness thank you and have you uh
experienced any foodborn illness reports
from soup
kitchens I'm trying to think back so
into my memory banks of when I started
here um and looking back at our outbreak
Tracking not particularly that I can
think of to souit kitchens we have um at
various outbreaks and events reported
from restaurant locations several um
either events such as like Pig roasts um
and community events to also um maybe
not really Church but other types of
events where people congregate and have
brought food in um and then also bring
that food the food items home and also
share it with their with their family
members who may not even also been
present there so we have seen kind of
secondary Transmission in other outbreak
events where people have brought food in
um and then also sometimes secondary
transmission from individuals who have
an infectious disease and individuals
can have personto person contact after
thank you I'd have to go look further
back though to provide you um specific
data to that though okay
representative Bixby you're next and
then represent so um I guess this is
sort of a followup on that so just uh
you you have seen evidence of um things
that like church suppers that sort of
community event uh how prevalent are
those it's a good question um we just
completed some uh data request for the
past two two years majority of the
outbreaks we've seen are personto person
typically neuro virus like illness
um but we have seen other illnesses like
salmonella um and I believe uh two so
one was associated with an outbreak and
I think um and other two were associated
with um maybe potentially I think raw
milk at the time um or exposure to
animals as well um we do also track
quite a few um National outbreaks as
well um related to either produce or
other items that have been shipped
across state lines represent Bixby
followup so
um trying to to break that down a little
bit more uh it sounds like
some uh some fraction of the uh the
contagion at those community events has
has to do with them being communal
events so congreg you know you get a lot
of people in the same place and uh some
of them may have to do with
contamination of the food itself uh that
would have may have been result of bad
preparation or bad handling uh do you
have any sense of what the breakdown of
that is I don't in front of me we can
look into that we'd have to look back at
quite a lot of number of years of data
um we do we there are several outbreaks
in recent history where it did look like
it was cross contamination due to People
to People interaction um but we have had
um pretty clear instances where there
was a contaminated food product due to
handling holding temperature issues um
and also very pretty rapid illness
because of toxin um that people ingested
that food later on um I'm thinking of a
like a turkey dinner for example where
individuals later on ate that and we did
have pretty clear evidence that it was
due to food practice and food handling
thank you representative Marie thank you
madam chair um thank you for taking my
question one of the questions I had was
around the Mobile Food units and I was
curious to know whether or not are those
are those something we currently license
and track and uh it's mentioned a few
times throughout the bill so I just was
curious as far as um how that fits in
this conversation so we were a little
unclear as to if Mo it does exempt
mobile units from a food license we were
understanding that to be only those that
were serving food made in an artisan
kitchen and not all mobile food units
but that was something we were a little
bit unclear with the the wording of the
follow up yeah um thank you
and um the other question that I had was
around products like kombuchas or other
types of fermented products that might
be there um are those would that be on
line I guess line four d uh 28 29 30 is
that a up page four on the amendment yes
pleas is that considered a high acid
food a low acid food just trying to
educate myself on where those would sit
so so kombucha is a we regulate that as
a beverage product it it is it does um
require
some review by an authority because what
can happen with kombucha is it be Can it
can become alcoholic over time and so
the producer would need to make sure
that they formulated it in a way that
they either marketed it as an alcoholic
beverage or that it didn't start as
non-alcoholic but due to the ongoing
fermentation become U an alcoholic
time any other questions represent Bixby
yeah so I'm trying to figure out um
where we go with this comparison of uh
being able to produce food for uh
something like a church supper or um
other other community event like that
where uh and and that allow maybe like a
um a bake sale or something that's
allowed because of its nonprofit
nature but um but it seems like in terms
of the actual food safety issues there
may be fewer food safety issues with
someone who's uh uh creating a a
relatively small number of meals in
their home kitchen and then selling
those to Neighbors
uh so I'm wondering where where does
that
F am I right in in in thinking that the
the producing a few meals for uh for a
fee for your neighbors might be a lower
risk thing than a church
supper you know I I think it's all about
the it comes down to the the greater the
volume of food you're producing there's
a there will likely be higher risk
you're either feeding more people you're
having to cook larger amounts of food
store larger amounts of food so it I
mean it's it's hard to parse what
whether a few um meals for what what a
few meals for your neighbors translate
do they equate we're you know because
occasional Food Services and temporar
events are exempt from our statute it
doesn't mean that there's not food
safety risks associated with those I
mean fairs in our Deerfield fair for
example there are is no inspection and
Licensing of the vendors there it it's
exempt from our statute doesn't mean
that there's not food safety risks
associated associated with it but but
it's something that's allowed follow up
follow up so uh if we were to uh add
something to this bill that would uh
limit the total number of meals uh in
some way that could be produced under
this exemption would that make it uh
would you be more comfortable with it
I I think we would be open to talking in
a in a a study manner on but Li again
opening um opening up to the type of
food that can be produced it's even even
um it's going to introduce more risks in
the current situation and again our
concern is without any license or
registration process for vendors our our
enforcement is is really will be very
very difficult or if at all okay thank
you representative Murray I thought you
had a question no representative H
Haskins oh the hair hand was over there
and then you're
next oh okay I just had another comment
to add to that I think it also depends
on the particular food product being
produced and being high risk or lower
risk and particularly around acidified
Foods or uh fermented foods could be
very high risk to botulism um which
though it's very rare and it's very rare
since we've had any cases in New
Hampshire there are still around 19 to
20 or so cases reported each year and
botulism is a very severe disease it
requires incredible fast medical and
public health response to the point to
treat someone with suspected
botulism we do get suspected cases
reported in we have to immediately
coordinate that response with the
Centers for Disease Control for
antitoxin so if you have even just a
handful of people that then had a a a
canned product that could be risky for
botulism we'd have to coordinate that
response pretty rapidly so I just I
think it depends on also the illness and
then the food that could be
prepared representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair um Miss Hansen I one of
the things I'm struggling with um
because I think this is a very serious
topic and I'm trying to educate myself
but the data that we have is all that we
know of and I'm thinking about the
scientific statement that absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence so
I'm assuming that it's your concern that
we would have more cases and more data
if we remove some of the restrictions
that are currently in place is that true
that's correct I think you said it
better than I did so thank you
bman thank you madam chair and thank you
for for taking my question I think to to
kind of piggyback on that question is
although we don't have specific evidence
for all the reasons you stated are is
there any way for the Department to make
a an educated guess can you speculate
which of course isn't evidence but I
don't know if if that's something that
you have and if there's anything that
you do with that information right
now sure so I don't have all of the data
in front of me so I couldn't bring it to
this table right now but we'd be happy
to look back at all of our data I do
actually I can leave this later it's our
monthly communicable disease report it's
only by counts by year so it's not
getting to the Nuance level that you
want but we can pull um data based on
the type of pathogen um so whether it's
estc or eoli or salmonela and uh
potential risk that may have led to that
illness um but it is important to
mention that individuals may have
multiple exposures so just because one
person had an exposure to a food they
may have also been exposed to their pet
or even a pet pet food product so it's
it is hard to really pinpoint exactly um
we're more likely to get that if there
is an outbreak or a national outbreak
where there's more data that can really
substantiate those claims and then also
be able to link um laboratory evidence
but we can look back at that and we'd be
happy to do that for you it will take a
little bit of time but we have um
epidemiology staff on hand that could do
that representative Murray um I just
wanted to if I heard you correctly in
your in your just your most recent
testimony when you're talking about
potentially pet transmitted are you
talking about potentially like raw Pet
Foods or things that contain like meat
or fish that are raw so a lot of these
anic pathogens are also zuno in nature
so a lot of our illnesses that we have
and and infectious diseases are often
zuntic where um not only ourselves as
humans can we get infected but also our
animals can or vice versa if we are pet
there's been actually pet food um
implicated outbreaks um and recalls with
pet food as well um so if an individual
get salmonella for example we'll do a
food history interview but we also ask
about pet exposures so that's just one
thing that we we look to as a potential
reason where someone may have become
ill so I'm again interested to know if
the department knows um for some of
these other states that have lifted some
of the restrictions on the foods that
have been produced and sold by Artisans
or Homestead people Farm
whatever if you have seen an uptick in
uh people getting sick or poisoned or
ingesting botulism or whatever have you
as a department seen any of that
evidence in other states that have
laws you know certainly we can query
those specific States I did see some
data from Wyoming um once they passed
their food freedom is in particular it
was Ill illnesses associated with with
raw milk consumption that their cases
definitely had a spike after their food
Freedom law was was enacted um as to the
other states that have been mentioned in
this testimony we could specifically
query those but I do know that some of
them um are very recent so there might
not be a lot of data a
available and I'll add to that I also
just briefly looked at Wyoming and they
they've seen an increase and I believe
it was salmonella and estc but I'd have
to look back again um over the past two
years um 2020 to 21 but again that data
is not all the way up to date so I think
we'd have to look back to see um and
then particular reasons for that but it
does look like they've also seen an
increase of some of anic
pathogens thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question
um I have two um some of the data that
you've been citing with salmon ill
outbreaks and botulism outbreaks are
those specific to New Hampshire or were
they National numbers sure thank you so
most of the ones I've rep spoken about
are for New Hampshire um for but I
mentioned 19 or so cases I think that
was 2018 or 19 that's reported National
numbers so that's the 19 is National um
New Hampshire I don't believe we' seen
we haven't seen a botulism case um
related to food uh for over 15 years we
have had a couple infant botulism cases
over the past um one I think one was in
2021 okay thank you second question
thank you madam chair and thank you
again um and you mentioned that there
were some people that you had to go out
and speak to um regarding food boor and
illnesses do you see re once you talk to
those folks uh do you see a repeat in
their behavior or is it usually from
someone else
that's a really good question typically
it's it's new individuals um so it may
not be from their own food prep or their
own behavior um we do so as a just for
awareness for the committee how we
conduct investigations if there is a
complaint that comes in we will follow
up on that with our colleagues at Food
protection or we will get laboratory
reports from Health Care Providers
suspecting an an anic or waterborne or
other pathogen that's under our statute
RSA 141c we receive that we do conduct
interviews of those individuals or a
medical proxy of all their risk history
and the foodborn questionnaires are
incredibly lengthy they're about four to
five pages long and it take could take
about half an hour to an hour to go
through those does the department uh
DHHS do they provide any kind of classes
or or online education for people uh who
are seeking to produce food so we we do
have a food safety 101 it's a 20 minute
video available on our website and we
also work very closely with UNH
Cooperative Extension they have several
um what they call Safe they're free
classes that they can attend online for
not only Farmers Market vendors um those
that work in food pantries or soup
kitchen environments or those that are
producing food they also have those
educational opportunities available
through through
ention okay so
um would it be a good idea to require
people who want to produce any kind of
artisan Foods or Homestead Foods uh
rather than require any kind of lure to
require them to have a food
safety class of some
sort so I think that would be a great
idea I I think the the problematic part
of it would be how do we enforce that
and and keep track that somebody has
actually done taken that class and then
what happens if they still continue to
produce food and they and they don't
haven't taken the class it it I think
it's it the idea has great Merit but it
would be very to put it other than an
honor System that someone's doing it and
tasking enforcement without some kind of
lure or registration process it would be
really difficult for us to Monitor and
know that that's actually taking place
okay thank you representative Bixby so
um a possible parallel might be the
mushroom foraging
program uh which I think is now up and
running uh or the um or or the meet the
chicken and the poultry and rabbit
program which um also provides a level
of certification but uh does not have a
whole lot of Department hand eyes
on so so the
the um mushroom forging they that
program they do have a a license that's
required so we would it's a five-year
license so that we do have a licensing
provision and then we do have an
educational provider through University
of New Hampshire who's agreeing to to do
the um educational piece but there is a
licensing component with that um the
poultry and rabbits they poultry and
rabbit producers are required to
register with the Department of
Agriculture if they choose to sell to
licensed
restaurants thank you sure okay any
other questions from committee members
seeing none thank you very much for uh
helping us out with with uh your
testimony today again I would call Keen
mang
Dr
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee my name is Keen May
Wong tax policy council with the New
Hampshire Department of Revenue um the
department does not have a position on
this bill however just wanted to
highlight a potential concern on the
language on the licensing uh similar to
the uh the language that was that I
highlighted in 15 HB 1565 uh HB 1685
also has a similar um
language regarding the exemptions of
Licensing is uh I do not have the uh the
amend the amended bill I only have the S
introduced bill is on page four lines 23
through 24 uh this is in regards to
Artisan food operations and it says that
they are exempt from all licensing uh
laws in this state um so in that sense
this would also uh be exempting these
license any questions from the
committee thank you we we are uh we'll
take that under advisement as we uh look
at possible future amendments to this
Bill thank you but um we certainly
wouldn't want to begrudge Dr from uh
you okay thank you call Megan Forbes
ahead there you go you thank you uh
thank you madam chair and thank you
again for the opportunity to testify in
support of this bill I'm not going to
repeat the points that I made earlier
but I just want to say again that we
support this bill as a way to safely
create Economic Opportunity and expand
economic Liberty for homebased food
producers um I just wanted to stress
again that seven states have enacted
similar laws that allow for the sale of
perishable food and some have been
around for several years now wyomings
being the oldest that's been around now
for nine years so um in terms of food
safety issues if there were a serious
food safety issue you would think that
we would see some food sa safety issues
at this point um and we we haveen it we
we've talked with the health departments
in those States and we haven't seen them
yet related to food that's sold from a
home kitchen um I I'm happy to answer
any questions that the committee may
have yeah do you know if any of the
other states that have enacted these
kinds of uh pieces of legislation
require um Artisan food makers to take
any kind of food safety courses or
classes Madame chair yes um every state
is different a couple of states have
required servesafe food handler training
for selling food that requires
refrigeration or potentially hazardous
food um food requiring time or
temperature control control for safety
one example is Oklahoma Oklahoma's law
has been around for a few years now and
in Oklahoma if you're selling shelf
stable food you do not have to complete
the Serve Safe training but if you're
selling potentially hazardous food you
do um and notably Oklahoma doesn't have
a license requirement but to qualify for
the exemption to sell potentially
hazardous food you have to um complete
training okay that's interesting
representative
kulong thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question uh could you
maybe speak a little bit about um
economies of scale because we do seem to
be conflating the distribution footprint
of like a kitchen based business and an
industrial size retail uh
operation representative kulan yes I'm
happy to talk about that um as I
mentioned ear
these are small based um producers we
often see producers preparing a few
meals um they're selling a limited
amount of food it's it's very very
difficult to sell a lot of food from a
home kitchen the home kitchen is
naturally limiting in its own way um and
as we heard before from the Department
it's really the the larger scale of food
where you start to see more
opportunities for food born illness come
in so I think that um plays to why this
is so
safe representative Bixby so do any of
the states that uh currently have uh the
uh the more open restrict uh laws on
this uh have any sort of restriction in
terms of the total number of meals sold
per week or anything like
that representative yes um some states
do and some don't most don't um but
occasionally we'll see gross sales cap
which New Hampshire recently repealed um
for I'll give you an example Iowa does
not cap shelf stable food but if you
sell food that's potentially hazardous
there's a $50,000 gross sales cap to
limit the food that's potentially
hazardous um Wyoming though has no sales
cap um I I don't think North Dakota has
a sales cap um so it really depends on
the state and and what we've seen in
reality is that sales caps of
$75,000 $100,000 don't really limit
homebased food producers because they're
not making that much to begin with so
cap anyone
else no other questions um thank you
very much I wonder if you might provide
the
committee um with some information
information of just
brief um features of each of the states
that have introduced these kinds of
bills um as you know for instance um
those that do have a a a cap on um
potentially dangerous foods uh those who
require food safety training um that
kind of thing I'd be interested to see
how each of those States of
um measured up on that do you have any
kind of uh uh data available on that yes
sure we'd be happy to compile that
information for you we do have all that
data and we could get it to you very
you okay seeing no other questions from
the committee I would like to have the
blue
sheet and um on the
online sorry oh uh for the online um
testimony submissions we had 19 people
opposed and on the blue sheet we had one
person in
favor with that I'm going to close out
1685 and I can give the committee uh
couple of minutes if you want
to go stretch your legs or something and
then we can begin our um our full
committee work session anybody want a
few minutes just
um that are different that
okay so I don't know if that count just
they went somewhere else let you know
yeah
and I want to go in order with them and
maybe if we spend about 20 minutes on
each or if we know uh
around that ballpark so that we are not
here until 7
o'clock
um uh I think the building closes at
um why don't we start with HP
1293 and I believe um so relative to
prohibiting the use of certain
fertilizers using phosphorus I believe
representative Bixby you've been working
with a number of different parties from
uh Department of Agriculture
Dees um Farm Bureau too um I think yes
and uh so what have you got what are you
working on and uh what are what are some
of the things that need to be fixed with
this bill okay so uh the uh one of the
questions that came up during our
hearing was uh are there things in this
bill that would affect uh anything other
than Lawns and Turf and the uh
the short answer to well the the answer
to that is as written there may be
however as intended there should not be
so uh so the bill was intended to be
really focused on runoff from Lawns uh
and uh so uh that's one thing that needs
to be dealt with uh in the amendment uh
so uh what I
what I did looking into the bill was I
uh talked to Alan Wyman at the
department uh of Agriculture and markets
and food uh because this is his uh
territory to work with and uh we came to
a few sticking points in terms of what
the bill was trying to do uh but uh and
then I um but we did talk about some of
the issues with the uh way that the
definitions were set up and that needs
to be um changed a bit and uh the so uh
director Ryman directed me to Ted deers
who is here from Dees today thank you
for coming in uh and uh Ted gave me a
lot of good information about um what
parts of the bill as written were
effective what were problematic what
should be changed uh in order to really
get the focus uh entirely on uh
preventing runoff from Lawns and uh I
also spoke with um Courtney eshbach at
OS and uh pointed out some of the
problems that I was having in terms of
trying to figure out how the bill was
put together and uh one of the things
she pointed out was that there are too
many definitions in the bill they we
don't need most of them because they're
re re iterated in the text uh there
needs that any definitions need to go
into a previous section of the of the um
of the chapter of law not not in um
section four uh one
431 uh 4B which is where most of the
bill is currently targeted and
the uh for Just for information 4314 a
and 4B uh are were were put in back in
2013 specifically for protecting water
water quality
and uh they deal with n but a deals with
nitrogen B de B deals with phosphorus uh
they're both really about what gets put
on
lawns uh except uh the way that they
were written has to do with what was
what is sold and one one big change with
this bill is how it's used and uh so uh
the existing law puts the onus entirely
on the retailers in ter and the uh
manufacturers in terms of uh selling
what they can sell for what purpose uh
this bill changes that so that it says
the uh owner or maintainer of a lawn
needs to follow a particular set of U
practices in order to avoid putting too
much nutrients on their lawn and having
them run off uh
so uh one of the key aspects of of that
is that there is absolutely no way that
anyone in in state government is going
to be able to enforce what any one uh
homeowner or lawn maintenance person is
doing with which B bags of fertilizer uh
it is so the key the key part of this
bill is really the education piece and
there is that education piece that has a
bit of text that needs to be posted near
the fertilizer section I think that the
actual text shouldn't appear in the bill
I think that it that parameters for the
text should and then the actual text
should be done by department rulemaking
so that it's a little bit more Flex ible
if they realize oh this isn't quite as
effective as we thought it was then they
can tweak it um and then that
educational material would be posted in
retail locations where fertilizers are
sold so that people will be educated
about how you know which fertilizer they
should use on their lawn and um how to
avoid putting on too much uh so uh I
think that that education part is really
critical um so I'm going to be working
with
um uh working with uh Mr deers and Mr
Wyman and uh also Eric satel who is here
from the Farm Bureau uh to uh and uh and
OSS to come up with an amendment that
moves things into the right part parts
of of the chapter uh excludes the parts
of the bill that are not really
effective and really focus it is focus
it Focus the bill on uh what the
definitions of what you can put your put
on your lawn are and uh how we can get
that information out to the public thank
you representative Bixby and I I do
appreciate uh the email that I received
from um Mr sautel had a lot of really
good um edits in in this uh
document uh and I hope that you'll
you'll consider those uh in your
Amendment and also I mean I was not a
real fan of making our um retail
establishments separate u bags of
fertilizer and put one in one place and
one in another I I think that that's
kind of a
burdensome thing I you know especially
if they don't have the space to do these
kinds of activities uh and and I hope
that um that that kind of thing is not
going to be included right so we can we
can avoid the separate locations part of
it the most important thing is having
the signage there saying this is what
you should be putting on your lawn this
is what you shouldn't be putting on your
lawn okay representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Bixby for really doing a
lot of uh leg work on this um my thought
is that we should put in there uh
depending on how you're drafting this
that agriculture as defined by RSA
234a should be exempt from anything in
this bill
because we are already guided on how we
can apply fertilizer when we can do it
Etc and all our setbacks and I don't
think that the agricultural Community
should have to be looking to another
area for their laws that actually was
included in U Mr satel's edits yeah so
he referenced that so the
the only so um by putting it into
431 uh 4B 4 a and 4B and making sure
that the language in those two sections
is really specific to Lawns that will
avoid the the bleed over into
agriculture uh the one place where there
is where there may be some uh ambiguity
uh is uh for golf courses and for sod
farms and for both of those uh I would
be putting I'll be putting in something
that says that those operations need to
have a nutrient management plan and if
they have a nutrient management plan
then they are exempt from the ex from
the conditions otherwise uh there was
also some question about um Frozen
Ground uh and um Mr sautel pointed out
very appropriately that uh four five to
six inches of frozen ground probably
isn't actually the right measurement uh
if the ground is frozen to 1 inch that's
you get just as much runoff as if it's
frozen to 5 in so it's a matter of if
it's less than one inch you might have
some fluctuation during the day uh so
late in the season if it's you if you
have half an inch frozen in the morning
and then it's um and then it warms up
during the day it might not be uh a
problematic to spread fertilizer if
we're talking about say mid April uh and
you already have grass starting uh but
the most important thing is that you
don't put nutrients down when there's no
when there are no plants to take them up
so that that's that's something that uh
a principle that that I'll also be
paying attention in terms of U putting
this together so is your intention to
also strike out uh the dates or months
that were mentioned in the in the bill
uh I think I'm going to consult with uh
Mr deers and Mr satel uh about uh
whether the appropriateness of those
dates because I think that there that
some some dates might it might be
appropriate to have some dates uh and uh
but I want to make sure I'm getting the
right one so I'm going to talk to talk
to people who are familiar with this
okay representative kraton thank you
madam chair uh representative Bixby I I
agree with the direction you're you're
taking this thing uh one question I have
is the signage is that a consum or is
that a retail owner responsibility to
purchase does the state provide those
and how are they paid for what are your
thoughts on that so uh what I I I took a
look at a couple of other states and
Maryland has some very nice signs that
they have available as PDFs on their
website that can be printed at different
sizes and uh I think that might be uh
the way to go because uh I I think that
printing out uh a few sheets of eight
and a half by 11 is not a huge financial
burden uh as long as the design is
doesn't require any particular work so
the department would make the signs and
and then they could be printed out by
retailers Roger thank you okay
representative Duty uh yes thank you um
I agree with the direction that you're
taking and I think this is a good first
step but interestingly enough there was
an article in the Boston Globe this
morning that says EPA study finds almost
no progress in River stream pollution
and there's a statement that says for
decades federal and state officials have
struggled to control Farm runoff the
biggest source of nutrient pollution
that is not typically federally
regulated and I'm thinking this isn't
obviously the bill for it but I think
sometime down the road we might want to
start at least uh maybe doing a study
committee or looking into
that yes so I actually happen to have
read that article as well and it was
really focused largely on Midwestern
states and uh I think that uh the one
thing that uh UNH has been doing a lot
of work on is studying uh nutrient
Management in um agricultural lands in
the state of New Hampshire and uh and
doing a certain amount of monitoring and
looking at patterns uh and I think that
we can reach out to UNH to find out uh
if there are generalized practices in
the state that need to to be modified in
order to account for that or if we're
actually doing fairly well on that on
the agricultural end so I think that
this is one thing where State specific
information is really
critical representative Murray um thanks
for taking my question this is actually
for Mr sautel if that's am I able to do
that sure I invite Mr sautel up to
the to the
microphone if you may take a question or
two and I want to thank you so much for
your uh your document that you sent
along with edits to uh to this bill they
were
helpful representative Murray thank you
madam chair so my question for you was
around um the I think it was around the
percentage available of phosphate and
you had mentioned that there might have
been some contradicting language around
it uh yes and and well two things first
that level is no longer that 67% is no
longer the level that probably we should
use if we're going to change the RSA
should be 0.
five and uh the section that you're
talking about I think
[Music]
is let me check
here in one place in in the existing
document in one
F you say uh phospherous contact tent or
phosphate or for phosphoric acid
whichever you use and I would say that
the same ter terminology should be used
throughout the document this as if I
recall from what representative Bell
said uh this was a conglomeration of a
number of different sources and they all
use different uh terminology so if you
just say available phosphorus which is
the title U word used throughout the
document I think it would be less
confusing to consumers but in one F in
the definition of phosphorous
fertilizer as written it says content uh
is greater
than and then
in um I
think farther down in the
it um
it also is in it's in 1f and Roman two
so Roman two
says cannot be greater than so which is
it uh which do you want it to be you've
got a
different different terminology in there
and I think just the wording uh the word
out does that answer your question yeah
so I can I can just give a little bit
more clarification in terms of what
process I'm going to use for that uh
there's an organization called I it's
a CO or some some combination of those
letters uh that is it's an organization
of uh industry groups and uh academic
groups that uh figure out what
definitions make sense
for uh fertilizer and soil amendments
and soil conditions Etc uh first for
laws in in States in order to get
basically get states to have very
similar definitions on in their laws so
they have they have a specific
definition for uh no phosphate
fertilizer and I'm going to be working
with director Ryman who has access to
their uh proprietary list of definitions
to um come up with to get as many of the
sort of nationally approved definitions
as possible for uh for the amendment
could I add one thing Madam chair sure
uh in in that
definition uh I think it would be who us
to put in the RSA particularly that what
you are talking about is a level of uh
expressed as p205 which is a chemical
formula that doesn't appear in anywhere
anywhere in the uh current legislation
it just says available phosphorus and
and if this is going to be an
educational piece I think that should be
included in this so everybody's is on
the same page some places use the word
phosphorus some places use phosphate
some PL places use phosphoric acid but
if it's expressed as p205 which is the
analysis it's not what's in the soil
it's the analysis uh that that chemical
uh formula does not occur in the soil
but uh that's what's in the
bag
okay so just a a little educational
Point beyond that there's actually an
awful lot of phosphorus in uh New
England soils bound up in a nonsoluble
form and uh a lot of that some of that
phosphorus can be ma made available to
plants by various microbial activity um
which is a which is one reason that we
don't need to put as much phosphorus on
as the as a soil test might initially
suggest uh the p205 is a high highly
soluble form which means that is very
rapidly available to the plants but also
can get washed away very rapidly if it's
put on in
excess uh in addition to that if I might
um the wording in in Roman 5B which
would be the signage aart it says most
New Hampshire soils
provide uh enough phosphorus that's not
true they may contain but they don't
necessarily provide it and there's a
myriad as I as I pointed out in somewhat
in my email uh there are so many
different physical and chemical factors
that that determine how much is
available to the plant and that would be
typically normally in one of a number of
different orthop phosphate uh forms most
of the commercial fertilizers sold or
synthetic fertilizers are in either
water soluble or citrate soluble orthop
phosphates uh and those are much more
available uh as represented Bixby said
to the plant key is don't put it on
there if the plant's not growing so
maybe the S the term the the term as far
as uh having dates in there the term
should be during the growing season only
season okay and that varies from I live
in Lee but the growing season a whole
Pittsburgh Point well taken
okay any other questions or comments
from the committee regarding this so it
looks like um the direction we're going
in with this bill uh as uh
representative Bixby is working with
these other parties is uh that that we
we seek to amend this
bill and
uh I guess that's all any
yeah do anybody have any
all okay all right well thank you
representative Bixby for um for your
efforts working with uh several parties
please let us know if there's anybody
from the committee that you need
assistance from all
right moving along to hb1 1294 relative
to prohibiting the state of New
Hampshire from enforcing the regulations
of the Environmental Protection Agency
that's um
1294 now we
heard uh we heard testimony about this
bill is it first of all I'm interested
to know if anybody's working on any kind
of amendment on this bill oh
representative Penza I see you wildly
raising your
hand you go right ahead please speak on
this then what are you working on so um
I don't support the the bill um but I
understand the reason why it was put in
and as I spoke during testimony so I
I'm it this is hard to to navigate in a
bill um you know there's uh constituents
that are of course in Rochester um
summersworth and in Dober that have um
that are kind of flipping out over this
so I'm trying to tackle this the best
way in protect ing overreach and in a
sense City or um Municipal governments
Town governments from signing on
something that is um going to tax um
going to tax the the citizens of that of
said town or city so that's really where
this is happening it's a Rain Tax what
and I mean every single person that was
on this I don't even know what you want
to call it commission study is um was
signed by a city manager um that put put
each City in a contract um so people's
land based upon how much land that they
have could get taxed for runoff which is
for rain it's really insane um
representative uh grer uh put in you
know let's just abolish it well we can't
do that but uh so it's kind of been
punted to me and um a constituent in
Dober really wants me to work on it so
I'm close um hopefully it'll be will be
there
soon okay so I I just wonder if the
amendment that you're working on would
be considered a non- gerine Amendment or
not I mean as the bill is written
certainly I I think um I don't want to
speak for anybody but me I mean I don't
think that we can nullify the EPA but I
do believe that there is a problem in
that the EPA has got some overreach here
they're mandating a community to do
something probably Based on data that's
not real anymore that's old and it's a a
huge burden and cost to that Community
um
so you know that's my thought on that
and I don't know what you know what you
might be able to come up with now
representative ger you had a a comment
and then I'll have represent ktoa before
you speak so I just wanted to speak to
German non- derness so the contract is
is truly um it's through the EPA in a
sense so I think that I mean I've
brought it up to um to the clerk he
feels it's Germain um because it's a
we're I'm bringing it down right so
we're saying non enforcing anything to
non- enforcing something that's very
specific okay so so you have spoken to
the clerk about it good thank you very
much for doing that representative ger
your comment yes thank you very much
much Madam chair and I wanted to um kind
of connecting to to your point Madam
chair around data what data we have what
data will be ultimately useful uh and
and uh representative Bixby and I had a
conversation after that hearing with
representative grassy from Rochester
he's familiar with these issues going
back uh years and one of the things that
that he pointed out was that there is a
dispute over the methodology uh which is
being used to determine the levels uh in
the Stream and that the EPA is insisting
on a particular methodology which is
when the body of water runs at its
lowest level uh which is when
concentrations are going to be the
highest um as opposed to obviously other
times of year when you're talking about
much lower concentrations so I wonder um
that led me to to to think that aside
from legislation that there's more to
the to to the issue here that the state
in its work with the EPA uh
representative Grassi was saying that
there are ways that the state would be
able to apply a different methodology
and then the outcome is going to be
different but that requires I think and
represented Bixby might be able to you
know your memory may be better uh uh
than mind with this but the state would
have to take over certain activities
that are currently being done by the EPA
in order for us to apply the methodology
so I mean that's something that I would
like to see explored because I I I see I
think this is a real issue I wish the
bill had addressed the real issue and
and I think that this question about how
we determine the concentration is
extremely important and what the EPA
does as opposed to what the state is
able to
do representative
K thank you madam chair
um representative Granger brought this
bill before us not to nullify the EPA
but to use it as a placeholder to
educate this committ committee on on on
this ongoing
issue I truly believe that is an
incumbent upon this committee that we
study this issue to get to the best
possible um solution for these
communities and it would be my
recommendation to an to do an interim
study on this
bill represent VI so
um I um I also there recognize and I
know that there is a real problem that
is being responded to with this bill uh
the bill as written is not a good
response to it I think we all recognize
that uh one of the so um there are two
things that come to mind one is that uh
this is this is something that clearly
needs study another thing that comes to
mind is that this is about this is about
a water quality issue and it is not
really the official purview of our
committee this would be bet the people
who are on the resources committee
actually know this territory much better
than we do uh so that's that's a couple
of thoughts the other another thing is
that um we have in the room right now
someone from the Water Division at Dees
who might be able to give us a little
bit more information about how this what
how this process is working if you'd be
willing to to come up and speak so Mr
good afternoon good afternoon Mr deers
Welcome to our committee thank you and
um Enlighten
us all right so for the record my name
is Ted deers I am the assistant director
of The Water Division at the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services I have been working on Great
Bay issues for about 20 years so I have
some familiarity uh with the situation
out there and I will say that it is
complex uh as has been intimated uh I
think through this discussion and it's
an interesting uh uh what I like to call
the dance between the federal state
local uh laws and regulations so um the
basic story is this is that in the early
2000s we began measuring uh in a robust
way uh nitrogen levels in Great Bay over
the last 20 to 30 years we've seen a
dramatic decrease in the uh eelgrass
which is a fundamental part of Great Bay
we've also seen a dramatic loss of
shellfish about 98% of the original
oysters that were in Great Bay are no
longer there we've seen a degradation of
water quality in the rivers that flow
into Great Bay with low dissolved oxygen
which is bad for fish and we've seen
other uh effects such as increase of
macroalgae that is sort of nuisance
algae that that floats around in the bay
all of these things have some
implication back to nutrients so this is
where we get to the conversation about
nutrients and why it ended up probably
in your committee so the the issue there
is is in F phosphorus is a problem which
we were just talking about uh largely in
lakes and rivers nitrogen is a problem
in estuaries and and in the ocean and so
the the challenge there is that you know
n nutrients are like it's it's food
right everything needs food um if you're
hungry and you eat one hamburger you
feel pretty afterwards uh if you're
hungry and eat a dozen hamburgers you
don't feel so good afterwards this is
the same issue and so in the Great Bay
as this started to become documented
well documented they were looking at the
relationships between nutrient nutrient
levels and and we can get very much into
the weeds if we want to talk about the
difference between concentration and
load which is fundamentally the
disagreement uh over the numbers uh the
EPA has put forward we can get to that
later but the issue really is how much
is to too much and so understanding how
much is too much has been a very
complicated and difficult conversation
for a dozen years or more and there have
been lawsuits um there's been courses
that uh cases that have gone uh through
appeal there have been all kinds of
permits um and there's been basically a
path put forward by EPA uh that
currently we're on and I think that's
been been referenced that there is a
permit there is a nutrients permit for
Great Bay that nutrients permit is the
result of the communities around Great
Bay asking for a more flexible approach
in meeting the reductions that EPA had
deemed was necessary in order to restore
the Estuary back to its previous health
so what they basically did was said okay
we'll give you a flexible approach the
flexible approach is this either we can
regulate your wastewater treatment plant
to a very very low level of nitrogen
output which is expensive or you you can
take on other alternative ways of
reducing your nutrient input it could be
from um you know protecting uh restoring
buffers along streams which has an
impact of of reducing nitrogen it could
be uh dealing with septic systems in
your community it could be dealing with
storm water um you know a lot of
communities have done a really good job
with storm water storm water is probably
about 30 to 40% of the nutrients that
which is reaching Great Bay comes from
Urban storm water Urban runoff that is
run off from your driveways from your
streets from your Lawns uh all of those
different uh
activities so so the point the the the
challenge of course is that this is
monumentally expensive uh If This Were
cheap we wouldn't be having this
discussion so the just the investments
in Wastewater alone Portsmouth just did
aund million upgrade exiter just
replaced essentially replaced their
facility with a 50 million up $50
million upgrade
New Market has tens of millions of
dollars in upgrades as does Durham uh
all of w whom are trying to really
reduce Rochester's done a phenomenal job
of reducing its its nitrogen output from
its wastewater treatment plant largely
by right requiring TurnKey landfill
which is which sends its leech eight
over to uh to Rochester for them to
treat at the site with reverse osmosis
that's been really successful at getting
lots of nasties out of the water
so all of this sort of comes together in
that communities are now making these
choices about how do they want to try to
meet the permit limits they can either
do it through the wastewater treatment
plant or they can choose alternative
methods and so the communities
themselves got together the communities
got together to decide how do we want to
go about doing this they formed an
alliance the municipal Alliance for
adaptive management and so it's made up
of the communities around Great Bay and
they've gotten together to to fund a
number of things one of the things that
they're funding is the science that is
the actual science of what is the right
level so how much is really too much so
that's really that's really good they're
putting they're putting lots of money
towards that they're putting money
towards uh best brager practices how do
you get how what are the best ways and
the cheapest ways to get nitrogen out
and they're also putting money into just
making sure that they do Outreach
together and that they push back on EPA
together um and so you know that's been
an important part of this is those
communities interacting to make sure
that they are getting their Fair shake
out of the federal government so all of
those are going on and I would
anticipate that if you were to go
further with this that you would
probably want to hear from those
communities directly because they're the
ones who are really impacted and and
they're the ones who are largely you
have their own destiny in their hands at
this
moment that permit this General permit
is going to be re um you know reissued
here in the next year or so
relative what we're seeing so far is
that EPA is relatively pleased with the
progress that's been made and that that
General permit is likely to be reissued
at the same time there's huge NSF study
as well as some other funding that's
gone into work at UNH as well as and the
communities have been contributing to
that on the orders of hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year in order to
get a better answer to this question of
how much is too much so that's going to
be ongoing and over the next couple
years as that science is really
completed and we have a much better
understanding somebody mentioned the
data and the timing on the data and all
of that there's a lot of work going on
right now I'm hoping that over the next
couple of years before the the
reissuance of the permit again that
there will be an ability to be able to
have a much better number uh this idea
of how much is too much so I know that
that was kind of a whirlwind trip
through um the trials and tribulations
of the nutrient issue on Great Bay for
the last couple of decades but but
that's kind of what got us here and it
is a pretty complex issue um my my
question is is the apaa asking for
something that's
unattainable that's a great question and
the answer is that EPA doesn't think so
and the Clean Water Act doesn't care
I'll be honest with you the federal
Clean Water Act says you're going to get
to a certain point if it does if it is
unattainable then they you know you can
do only what you can do but at this
point it's not clear that it's
unattainable and so those restrictions
will you know continue to be placed on
the communities are there exemptions
that EPA will
allow there are exemptions uh there are
exemptions that they put into these
permits relative to how well the
community um you
know how how hard is it for them to get
there they can put time extensions on
things they have been very flexible on
some of those things so yeah there there
are some exceptions but really those are
you know the Clean Water Act is
relatively strict on how that works
because I know you know in dealing with
the federal government especially in in
my towns where we're dealing with FEMA
for instance and then I know they're two
totally different worlds but you know
there there are some things that a rural
community can't deliver to FEMA when
we're looking for reimbursement for
flood damage or whatever and we can work
with them through Department of Homeland
Security to sort of run inter
for the small towns and Rural
communities that can't meet
certain um Expectations by the federal
government and I'm wondering is that
what you guys in dees are doing to help
these communities who are finding that
some of these requirements from the EPA
are too honorous and too expensive that
um their their tax base simply can't
afford the kinds of things that EPA is
requesting them to do do you guys run
interference for that
Community um to help them obtain some of
these exemptions you bet we thank you
for the question we we definitely um
work very closely with the communities
to try to get them the best shake that
they can we don't write the permit EPA
writes the permit so so we are in a
position where we you know sitting in
between the communities and EPA that
said we have provided um as much funding
and as much flexibility on funding as we
possibly can lots of loan
forgiveness um we have $185 million of
arpa funds that we're currently putting
towards water infrastructure in the
state many many of those dollars are
going to the communities uh around Great
Bay and and in that Watershed to be able
to upgrade their facilities our srf
grants we've done a lot of those as well
as with and with loan forgiveness there
as well so we're trying as hard as we
can
uh to fund uh to the best we can to help
those communities to find the funding to
do the work that they um need to do
because the bottom line is that um the
cost to doing these kinds of projects
and and everybody wants clean water
everybody wants uh to have great Bay
look great and and not be you know
problematic but there there has to be
some kind of um B bance between what the
communities can afford in terms of their
taxation uh and what can be delivered uh
in terms of of trying
to Monitor and prevent clean up whatever
the issues having to do with
nitrogen I'm representative
kraton Mr deers thank you madam chair Mr
deers is as always it's nice to hear
from you it's you're on the other side
of the wall what happened I don't know
you you got lost
somewhere uh so as I read this bill
there's there's acute pain going on
right now and what you describe to me as
a process of give and take between local
state and federal and that it's painful
but they're going through it but are you
aware of why we have a bill in front of
us saying to abolish the
EPA not really I I I sort of understood
it had something to do maybe with Milton
or do I wasn't quite sure EX what was
the the the situation and happy to you
know hear more about that absolutely
okay thank you question representative
Bixby yeah so um I'm wondering is uh is
there something that uh you need you
would need from the legislature in order
to enable you to uh work better with
this
issue it's a good question um you know
money always helps
uh so so there again there's a couple of
there's a couple of decision points here
um one is
that is this idea of you know how do we
determine what that right level of
nitrogen is and it's a and it's a really
seriously complex research question that
has engaged you know dozens of
researchers right now so certainly
getting that through that will help to
inform whatever is the next permit just
to explain sort of this in in some in
some rough terms there's there's been
serious controversy about what's
actually causing the problem in Great
Bay is it is it too much nutrients is it
is it too many too much sediments coming
out of the rivers into the Great Bay is
it a combination of things which are the
driving forces that are causing this to
happen because it's it's this this idea
that certainly in all other estuaries
that we know know of around the world if
you put too many nutrients in they cause
bad things to happen so so so that
certainly has driven a lot of the the
permitting to date is understanding that
from other places but understanding it
better here so that is one place in
which you know I think continuing to to
put pressure
on uh to be able to get to those kinds
of answers are fundamentally at the end
of the day what will drive uh what's
going to go into the next set of
permits represent Marie
thank you madam chair um thank you for
taking my question um so I guess my
question to you would be as far as I I
think I understood you said UNH was
undertaking some of this the study on
what causation versus correlation I
guess to kind of talk about some things
um when do you expect to see some of
that data coming back to you yeah I I
expect that you're going to see some
pretty significant um uh papers coming
out in the next year because that really
is what's going to
um you that's when that research is
largely going to have some conclusions
to it and that will start a long process
I mean because once you sort of
understand what's a more appropriate
level of of of nutrients that that we
should be shooting
for it's going to set off a whole chain
reaction of well then how do you
actually figure out who's responsible
for that and and that that will then
take a while for that to get figured out
this is not this is it's taken a long
time to get to this point it's going to
take a while to get back out of it so
then my question is if if we don't know
specifically what's causing the problems
in Great Bay how can
we how how does the EPA then come out
and say well you have to do X Y and
Z if they don't know what the problem
really is why are they mandating us to
do things that may or may not solve the
problem well because they pretty sure
that they know what the problem is okay
gocha okay representative
Duty thank you thank you for taking my
call so when we had the public hearing
the the message that I got from the
people that spoke in favor of this bill
um was that they can't afford it they
don't want it and there's no problem
okay and how you know so so I saw it as
an issue of we don't want to be taxed
for it I'm not sure that that's clear
but I would say you know in nashwa where
I live we have combined sewer overflows
we've been you know I think 35 years ago
when they tore up my street they took
the storm water you know I mean they've
been doing that uh we now have a charge
every quarter for wastewater treatment
um you know it costs us a lot of money
to do that so I mean if we have to do
that in in places like like Manchester
and and man Manchester and
Nashville then you know why should rural
communities be exempt from having clean
water you know having wastewater
treatment facilities that meet
specifications just because they don't
think they can afford it is that what
you're hearing as part of the argument
because that seemed to come through to
me when I when I heard it and I not sure
it's correct yeah no it's it's a great
question I think the question is one of
proportionality right that those who are
the most responsible for the problem
hold the greatest you know
responsibility to try to fix it and what
we know about Great Bay is that those
communities which are closer into Great
Bay bear more of the responsibility so
you know the doers and portsmiths and
and exitor um they certainly have a
great deal more
of if you look at nitrogen inputs that's
where more of it is coming from so when
you get out towards Milton and some of
the other communities
surrounding um what you do see is that
they're what they're being required to
do is much much less than what those
other communities are required to do
right around the periphery of Great Bay
and so that that you you do see that
proportionality um that is and that's
really about kind of where is the source
of this stuff coming
from I think does that get out what you
sorry it just seemed to me like uh it
was a tax issue that that I shouldn't
have to pay for it I'm not part of the
problem um and and I don't have any
money anyway but you know I mean you can
use that argument anywhere but in NASA I
mean we just get build for it I mean you
know I mean I don't really have a say
about wastewater treatment you know I
mean you know we have uh combined SW
overflows it flow flows into the marac
river we've got speci specifications and
regulations that we have to meet okay
and and it seems to me that other parts
of the state when they have these issues
arise um you know they feel that they're
being unfairly treated and that they
should be exempt and you know I'm not
sure why we would even want to consider
a bill and I know this is a misplaced
bill but why we would want to even
consider a bill um that would give
priority over to a community when every
other community in the state has to meet
Clean Water and Wastewater regulations
yeah I see what you're saying okay
representative Penza um and and I I just
as a point of order to that um
representative ger brought up um I I
know that we we need to get a better
background about what the problem is
that this bill is reporting to solve um
and I understand too that the committee
is not uh overall not in favor of of any
kind of nullification of the EPA but we
do need to have a good understanding of
why what what the problem is and if the
if in constructing any kind of amendment
um that would address that problem I
think would would be helpful so
um we're we're running a little short on
time but I I do want to entertain your
comment yeah I have a bunch of questions
so I'll just I'll I think I'll just use
one so you were talking about um when
you were talking about the grape a and
what's going in and um
nutrients um the one thing that is not
being talked about at all has to do with
the pollution that's going in Great Bay
and and they're they're only they're not
really looking at that at all because
you're talking about all these changes
right they're they're not looking at
that they're they're they're wanting to
pin it on nitrogen and all that kind of
stuff so the constituent that I have
that's in Dober
has literally had UNH done all of the
testing she has data that's showing
that's completely conflicting to the EPA
she's had a farm for a long time so
meaning for her runoff because she has a
lot of land and would get a lot it would
cost her a lot with this rain tax um so
she's got data running through the UNH
which is incredible that's showing that
the nitrogen levels have actually
decreased so and that's that's huge too
because we low nitrogen causes all these
other types of problems so there's so
much conflicting data and I I think it
what it really comes down to is this
level of overreach but no one's really
talking about the pollution into into
Great Bay and I don't know if that has
anything to do with the sewer systems
and all of that kind of stuff but you
know I understand that it is you
constituents had no idea that this was
hitting them and um and there just
hadn't been any communication
and at that do it all started with a um
with a do city council meeting when it
was unanimously you know uh shut down in
regards with like the Rain Tax so and
the other thing I wanted to ask you was
money like you said money so you know
what could you have what what do you
need the money for is my question you
said what are you looking for money for
if I had one so this great great
question what would I do if I had a
million dollars um or or a 10 million or
100 milli ion what we would do is we
would pass it to the communities so
that's what we do with money that we get
so if there were dollars if the
communities had needs uh to treat
pollution because that's really what we
are talking about I mean we are talking
about pollution now again there's
certain components of that pollution
which cause various different things to
happen in the environment um and I will
just say that the UNH is also looking at
things other than nutrients they're
looking at a lot of things but it's not
just nutrients
because there are lots of different what
they call confounding factors involved
this this idea of correlation versus
causation getting a better handle on
what's the causation so you know I think
if there were dollars to be spent it
would be from for things the very things
you're talking about getting a better
handle on storm water getting a because
that's where the that's where so many of
those nitrogen that is coming from the
the the nutrients are coming from storm
water so if you're looking at where's
that storm water coming from well it's
coming from you know parking lots and
and and driveways and sidewalks and
Lawns and all of that other stuff so
yeah if if if there were dollars to be
spent on things and again we were
blessed with $185 Million worth of arpa
funds all of those dollars are going out
to communities just like yours
representative Bixby yeah so we've been
discussing this bill for a while and I
think one thing that is very clear is
we're not going to get it resolved on uh
this afternoon right uh I think that we
have a couple of a few potential paths
forward uh one is we could just throw up
our hands and say it's too hard and itl
it another is that we could say we're
not going to solve it in the next two
weeks maybe we should um take this on as
an interim study in our committee
another possibility would be to convert
it into a study committee and see if we
could get uh a couple members of
resources onto that study committee
because uh that resources really has a
much broader sense of experience with
this bill than we do but I I would
propose that we um bring our
conversation to this bill on this bill
to an end and and consider one of those
two study options as a as what we should
be thinking about going
forward I
agree
okay just a quick question
representative Penza yeah for
representative Bixby so if this went to
the second piece that you said in
regards with um a study committee that
could possibly have um some resources
folks on it would then would we pull
legis I mean depending on what is the
goal of that to possibly put forward
legislation
or yes so the goal of a study committee
would be to
uh look at the look at the look at the
entire issue uh and bring in as many
experts as we can to explain to the
study committee uh what What's what the
issues are and uh what the possible ways
of dealing with it it are and then the
study committee would uh look at the
information they had and say this is
something for which we have a potential
uh leg legislative solution or at least
some legislation that could help and
then they would file that legislation
for next uh next term uh and so that's
uh and I would be lean more towards a
study committee rather than a study
interim study because with a study
committee we could get people from
resources onto it agree yeah represent
Murray thank you madam chair and I just
wanted to uh just sort of
bring back into the fact that there is
some ongoing research out there that
we're expecting data within the next
calendar year so how does that factor
into the the the study Avenue that we're
instructing people to go down well I
think that um the people who are
studying it from UNH and from Dees would
definitely be on the list of people
invited to speak with the study
committee even though it's not yes
because
in research is always ongoing and
there's always some information that new
information that you have actually
figured out and there's always something
that you still realize you need to look
into further so uh there's there's not
going to be a point where suddenly we
know everything it's going to be so I
think the study committee will be able
to figure out what the most current
information is and use that in order to
make a judgment about legis future
legislation okay all right I think we've
said enough about hb12
94 let's move on to cacr 14 thank you Mr
deers for uh lending us
sometime uh cacr 14 relating to the
environment and natural resources
providing that the state shall maintain
and improve a clean and healthful
environment for present and future
Generations um I open it up to comments
this okay I don't see Hands flying up in
the
air yeah go ahead representative
kraton thank you madam chair uh looking
at
cicr uh
14 um I agree with everything that's in
it but I don't think
it's worthy of going into the as a cacr
I think it's already in there and that
uh it it could Cloud the issue further
and so
uh I agree with it but in the testimony
we heard it just it seemed to me that
was redundant and it would cloud the
issue rather than amplify the
issue
over okay representative Bixby yes so um
I'm uh I I think I'm probably going to
come to the same uh end point as my
colleague but um I I think that uh as
written it does not
really
uh it it does not quite capture the
issue exactly and I think it may in fact
be a useful thing to have something like
that in the Constitution at some point
but I don't think that the language as
presented is uh good enough I also think
that it is very unlik to get very far in
this legislature so I think there's no
point in spending much effort on it and
I would um be inclined to say this
should be an
I I would be in agreement with that
representative
Bixby representative ger you have your
hand up yes I do thank you madam chair
uh
I kind to see the path that that we're
going on I understand that I accept that
but uh I I do want to to say that you
know we've seen recently in Wyoming the
the impact that something like this can
have to actually have a constitution
Montana thank you I'm sorry Montana
thank you uh that that there are real
world consequences for having something
like this in your Constitution uh that
if you
prioritize natural resources in public
health uh then at some point the rubber
has to has to hit the road and the
Constitution is the place where we uh
enshrine where we codify the rights that
are to be protected
to me these rights are as fundamental as
any other so uh I I understand as I said
where we're headed I I accept the
reality of it but I I do also want to
say that I think that a point that I
made during the hearing I'd like to just
reiterate which is that particularly
when it comes to Dees one of my
frustrations I tremendous respect for
the folks at Dees and the work that they
do but it is not oriented toward
Environmental Protection Environmental
Services I've had this discussion with
some folks at Dees before it's a
permitting agency you tick the boxes you
get the permit that to me is not what
that agency should do as you said this
is actually a reflection of
conversations I've had with with with
the director whimsi in particular with
regard to why certain things could be
done and can't be done and that
effectively is the answer uh so in any
event I think an amendment like this the
benefit of it would be to to have the
effect of directing agencies like Dees
to the job of Environmental Protection
which is not the fundamental mission of
Dees as it currently
exists represent dsy yeah uh just
quickly I I agree with the you know that
this is not the vehicle but I also think
that we might want to do an ad hoc
committee to see uh about putting a bill
forward and that's primarily I think
because um it can be a symbol of Hope um
for young people uh you know I've been
reading recently how young people feel
that um very hopeless about the fact
that their environment is being trashed
and there's nothing that they can do
about it and I think for us to have some
kind of a statement like this in our
constitution uh sets up you know a a
goal uh shows that we are concerned and
that we want to leave a better Planet
you know to Future Generations uh than
what we have right now
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair just to agree I think we are alone
or almost alone with the District of
Colombia in not having something like
the protection of our environment and it
was such a surprise to me when I started
that I should have known but I did not
know that the Department of
Environmental Services was not here here
to protect the environment so I must
agree with the two or four mentioned
speakers that we should have it in our
constitution because I don't believe
it's happening in quite the way I hoped
it would thank
you I would just say that
um I don't believe that it should be put
into our constitution I don't think that
that's the place for it I also believe
that um and New Hampshire Dees is not
just a permitting agency or regulatory
agency they have a mission statement
their mission is the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services is
to help sustain a high quality of life
for all citizens by protecting and
restoring the environment and Public
Health in New Hampshire the protection
and wise management of the state's
environment are the main goals of the
agency so um the state statute RSA
21- um Dees was leg legislative created
legislatively Created through the
consolidation and reorganization of four
previously separated agencies so uh to
say that we need a constitutional
amendment to enshrine uh whatever the
wording is in this bill I think is
um it's just it's not
necessary
representative kraton okay thank you
ma'am I I just just for the record I
guess which so I I chair the Exotic
Aquatic weeds and species committee for
the State of New Hampshire and that
primary one of the primary people on
there is from
thees and uh I I will tell you that what
has been said here about DT Dees could
not be further from the truth I mean
that that lady on that committee is
completely dedicated to the preservation
of clean Waters in the state and she
works overtime more than anyone I know
and and will'll respond to anyone in
this state and her only or only mission
is the preservation and protection of
the waters in this state and so to
disparage thees as a block checking
organization I think is completely
disingenuous and so I I don't mean to
get upset but these are really good
people and they are focused on
preserving our environment as it is and
that that's just having dealt with them
straight up for the last four
years get off my stove box
thanks sir I appreciate representative
Cron's point and and I want to clarify
my own which is not about the people who
work at Dees I don't doubt that at all
and I know as a fact that what
representative kraton is true but I also
have talked to people at Dees who feel
boxed in because the processes are
permitting Pro or are are primarily
permitting processes I've been in um
meetings with the previous was he the
assistant commissioner Mr sandborne uh
who repeatedly made it clear uh that
their job was to balance business
interests with environmental interests
uh so I I just want to clarify
appreciate representative kraton's
comments I want to make it clear that I
have the greatest respect for the folks
at Dees and I've never met anyone there
who isn't absolutely committed as
representative Katon said it is the
they're the processes within the agency
that ultimately do when it comes to air
quality permitting for example or
landfill permitting if you tick the
boxes uh we do not air on the side of
Environmental Protection right we you
check the boxes you get the permit and
as you said that is not a reflection of
the commitment of the folks in Dees to
environment one last comment and then I
want to move on
please so if we're going to go back to
the Constitutional amendment I don't
think it's necessary I think there were
um lots of point points in there that we
are that that are protected you know
life liberty property Pursuit of
Happiness all I think all those things
are um you know even things that are in
there that just enshrine with our rights
and consent and all that kind of stuff
um in regard in being good stewards so
uh I just wanted to piggyback on on what
representative Jama said because I
literally have had uh four conversations
where I I've been told that same thing
that they
um they can't they they can't look they
it's I don't want to say it's not common
sense but they can't look outside that
box so if everything you know even
though we know something that's a that's
an issue we don't um we we don't really
look outside of that if everything falls
in it falls in line and so it's not
process representative kulan thank you
madam chair I I just want to say I'm
completely against this this bill and I
think the only function it would serve
is to be a placeholder for court rulings
and uh yeah I don't support it okay
thank you all right we're gonna move
on from
cdr4 to discuss um HB 1630 relative to
Extended producer
responsibility
[Music]
um can
can
um okay yeah let's let maybe we should
set some time limits here because I know
we can have this discussion till 8
o'clock
tonight
um for me this is a rather large and
complicated uh bill it is introducing a
whole new level of um of
um government we are uh the es has
claimed that that they would need eight
positions to support uh the provisions
in this
legislation
um the bill itself would have a two to
foure
implementation
um there's a lot of work to be done
between you know Dees study and
rulemaking and it
was discussed um
in testimony and also amongst some of
our colleagues here in the
committee that
um while there are some states around us
that are either started to implement
eppr legislation and those who are
considering it
um we've yet to see
really how the implementation has gone
if it's it's gone well if there are
things that um could be done better or
different and
so I think that you know this particular
bill um would need significant amendment
to it I don't know if anybody is working
on any amendments to this bill but I
think the way it is in currently um is
probably not ready for for Prime Time
representative Duty yes uh Madam chair
you know I agree with you I mean I epr
uh we we should be considering epr we
should be studying epr and it's not um
just focused on EP when we get a very
complicated bill that is going to make
numerous changes um you know to to the
implementation of certain processes and
and this is a very comp complicated bill
I think we owe it to our constituents
and everybody to look at it very
carefully so I would hope I mean that we
use this as as a basis and that and I
I'm not sure how we move forward if it's
a study committee but that we have a
vehicle where we can study it over the
summer where we can bring in experts to
really do work sessions not just
testimony but work sessions and and uh
and try to craft a bill that we submit
in the fall that you know could be a
first step for New Hampshire you know I
don't want us to bite off so much that
we're going to fail but I do think that
there's a lot in this bill that we could
use as a template to move
forward okay um I get to you after me I
I think that
um I agree with with you and I think
there's a lot of parts of this bill that
I would like to see the solid waste
working group examine um the the the
committee that uh representative eel
chairs um I I would love to have the
solid waste working group maybe have a
subcommittee or something to take a look
at the provisions of this kind of
legislation and see what pieces of it
would fit what pieces make sense what
don't make sense for New Hampshire so
that's kind of where I am with that and
you know I don't know if we want to then
say you know interm
study or you know just pass something
like this along to the solid waste
working group for them to consider
representative
brard I I part uh part of me agrees with
representive Duty I I think we need to
see the proof yeah Maine we need to see
the proof Oregon California that this is
working for your state it's lessening
the financial burdens on
municipalities um is is that the case is
is it putting any additional financial
burden on the consumer uh I think we
need much more feedback from producers
in general what we again I I don't need
to hop on the uh initial study committee
that I was on but we did not nearly um
get as much feedback uh as we should
have from from producers from the
manufacturers and so I think I think
that's the uh the overall uh big one for
this thank you representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair I'm not in a
position to know what the best path
forward is I wish I did I do know that
Source reduction is the number one goal
in New Hampshire for Waste Management so
that line sort of stuck with me as okay
here's the problem how do we get there
and again it's big it's massive and I
wish I had
constructive advice about how we get
there I just know we have to start we
have to make a plan and um I hope that
the study committee if that's the way we
go could do that well I know with the um
the the go key goal of source reduction
that the solid waste working group is a
vehicle is working on that um along with
the stakeholders that are on that
committee and
um the representative from the Senate as
well as uh representative from Dees um
and I think you know the the key points
to this
legislation is Source
reduction it's how we get there and
whether it's working
elsewhere representative uh Na you had a
thank you madam chair I just really want
to Second what she had to say which is
we heard a lot of times during the
testimony that reducing the source of of
waste was the number one goal of these
different committees that have studied
it so you know I'm not a fan of asking
for study committees and asking for
reports and then not following their
recommendations the other piece that you
know I'm sure all of us took from the
testimony was the recommendation that it
would need it would require eight staff
members a Dees so you know I I think
doing an interim study or I think
contining to look at this legislation is
really important yeah there needs to be
a balance between those two things right
like we probably don't want to add eight
sta people right but we do need to start
working on this exactly represent
sofikitis
is there some mechanism involved with
asking the speaker to move this to the
solid waste working
group um no but you know this is
certainly a topic that they are um they
have they will have on their plate that
they do have on their plate because it
is a a one of the mechanisms to achieve
um Source reduction representative Bixby
yeah so one of the uh people who
testified uh mentioned that Maryland is
doing a um a need to assessment which is
a preliminary step to doing uh their epr
bill so they don't they don't have they
aren't they haven't fleshed out an epr
bill as a whole they are doing a needs
assessment I don't I haven't looked at
that
uh carefully but my sense is that uh
what that in involves is having someone
in their um their equivalent of Dees who
is actually paid to work on figuring out
what would need to go into an epr Bill
uh I'm uh I'm wondering if that so I I'm
I see two possible ways forward with
this uh one is uh seeing if we can mend
it to do such a such a needs assessment
I think we might it might be tight on
the time frame but it it might be
possible to to figure out A needs
assessment uh bill that would replace
this to to create an initial first step
the other other possible mechanism would
be uh to do an interim study uh as
representative Duty uh suggested uh
where we would you know in this
committee figure out what the next steps
are um I think that
uh the um it's the fact that we don't
have uh Buy in from industry on this yet
means that it's not going to as as as it
is currently written it's not going to
go it's not going to be effective
because the only way you can do epr
successfully is if you do have industry
Buy in I
agreed representative ger and then
Penza thank you madam chair uh I also
support interim study because I I I
think I want to Second what
representative NAB said which I I think
articulated it well I I also just want
to on a cautionary note around data we
like data when we like it we don't like
it when we don't like it right I mean
the study the study includes evidence
from I think five or six provinces in
Canada which shows that there is no
correlation discovered between epr
policies and cost right so we don't like
it because it's Canada right well if
it's California maybe we don't like it
because it's California right
uh well but again we there is data that
that the study was basing uh the its
conclusion that this is not going to to
provide a cost shift there is data for
that so it's not as if we don't have
data so I just wanted to put that there
as a cautionary note right if we're
going to say that there is no data when
there is data that concerns me that
we're we're choosing which data we see
as worthy of acknowledging and which we
uh choose to set aside representative
Penza
wow I have to go after that just kidding
um
so I just you know I'm not sure if the
study committee um um you were part of
that correct okay so during that study
committee um
what you weren't happy with kind of the
results it didn't seem to right
correct okay so I just don't understand
why the representatives that are um that
are proponents of this haven't gone to
these were my kind of questions haven't
gone to our federal delegation because I
believe that that's where this starts I
mean if if you want industry buyin you
need to have that on such a you have to
have that on a national level which then
will equate down to a local level I
agree with we need to have with with the
source with what representative has
Haskins said but why aren't we why and
our representativ reaching out to our
federal delegation to try did you guys
talk about that at all in your study
committee it was very limited uh again
it was a
4day study committee uh and
so again what we what we talked about
was very limited uh again we didn't look
in any state statute a particular State
Statute and analyze it word by word uh
and so
it's
yeah that's pretty much representative
kulan thanks for taking my question so
there is actually there's conflicting
studies and data and evidence on this
subject even um you know
institutional uh sources that support
epr do say that it is a natural
byproduct of epr policies that it does
affect prices and price increases will
be put on to the the consumers and I'm H
I'll be happy to forward it to you guys
and another point is that uh with the
issue of out estate waste and Source
reduction we would need Massachusetts to
pass epr policies to cut down on if
there's 50% of ways coming from Mass we
need them to sign on to epr too they do
have
epr I'm sorry but Massachusetts has a
bottle bill which is the foundation of
epr so I mean I don't know why you you
know and it has nothing to do with epr
their trash coming into Hampshire is
because they're passing restrictive laws
and closing landfills has nothing to do
with
epr uh let's
uh a little decorum
Howard I think the bill is
I think the bill before us is is
actually like three or four bills so um
what I want to say two things about
about the the um the subject one of them
is that we sort of need to treat this
like a super fun cleanup you know that
where where the the industry takes
responsibility and and the other thing
that I want to say is we need to make a
commitment to this as a committee what
no matter what we do we need to be
behind it and and make a strong
representative
kraton yes ma'am so I'm just trying to
to dig off and perhaps um representative
basally help me out here so intern an an
interim study comes back to the
committee whereas if you send it to a
subcommittee then that is it could be an
established subcommittee or one that we
propose but those members in there would
include members of Industry members of
nonprofits members of different agencies
involved okay that's a study all right
so okay that's okay a study committee
but not interim study so there are there
are several different ways of studying
things interim study is within the uh
policy committee a study committee is
within the legislature so it's just
House and Senate members uh and and
those members have the power to uh call
witnesses from wherever and uh the
witnesses can either say yes or no will
come uh and then a a commission is uh
members of the legislature plus uh
stakeholders from Beyond the legislature
and those stakeholders are appointed by
Often by the governor sometimes by other
bodies that they represent or or
recommend Ed to the governor by bodies
they represent um in terms of the ease
of Passage uh an interim study is the
easiest thing to pass and then you get
and then a study committee is the next
step and then it's much harder to pass a
stud a commission uh because there is uh
and in terms of ease of running it's
probably uh some the interim study and
the uh study committee are probably
similar in terms of the ease of running
it a commission is more complicated to
run because you're coordinating more
people from more places uh you uh do
have the advantage of having those
stakeholders in the room with the
commission uh and uh so um generally if
you're looking at a fairly
broad-reaching
complicated problem uh then a commission
might be more suited towards it uh if
you're looking for looking at something
that is uh you're trying to figure out
the nuts and bolts of legislation in
fact an interim study might be better uh
an interim study if we want to make sure
it happens an interim study is the is
probably the best bet because if we make
it into a study bill uh a study
committee the Senate May say not so much
and then it goes away it doesn't
happen Okay thank you representative
ktoa thank you madam
chair so in listening to this and in
listening to the uh represent brard talk
about how they couldn't get the
producers to come to testify in front of
their committee but yet we have
producers sitting on the solid waste
working group
already I would think that that would be
the more pertinent Avenue to take um and
asking them to do it because you already
have the stakeholders on the in the
group and can be there to readily answer
any questions and it also is part of
what their goal is that's my personal
Murray thank you madam chair um I just
want to be clear um we do have to decide
on a disposition for this bill so if
there's nothing to say
that that may be the desire of
individuals to have swag take it up but
we don't have the authority to ask them
to take it up is that correct right and
so
um but what I think I so I think but to
my point I think interim study would
give us the best possible opportunity to
be able to take a look at what is before
us and kind of parse out what is
implement able in the short-term medium
longterm of this very complex D Bill and
get some additional input like
representative Bixby was mentioning
represent Bixby so there was one other
thing that I had mentioned earlier was
the possibility of um rewriting it to uh
be a um uh a feas was the term I Ed
needs assess a feasibility assessment or
needs assessment and uh I was wondering
if I we could ask representative partial
if that is an amendment that he would be
willing to try to put together in the
next couple of
weeks um okay um just briefly yeah I
will try to be deef and I want to thank
you um I would tend to agree that I
think one of the real stumbling blocks
with this right now and there are a few
one of them is the
uh uh assessment by the DS uh the needs
assessment and I think that that would
be an appropriate place to try to see if
we can move that uh stumbling block as
it were with an amendment to the bill
that focuses really just on that aspect
of it um I I would be more than willing
to draft something got effect and uh
then at the same time I do have to agree
with uh representative brard four days
really wasn't enough time and I would
also remind the committee that
originally this bill the bill that was
the Genesis of this legislation came
before us requesting a study
commission and upon the I think in the
retrospect the sage advice of this group
we did reduce that to a committee rather
than
commission um I don't know if they would
be willing to take a second committee on
last point I'm sorry I'm going on here
uh at the time the uh Solid Waste uh uh
commission was in here they
expressed not a lot of not a lot lot of
they they they really like the idea of
epr but they were questioning whether or
not they were the appropriate Avenue of
it at that time if you remember they
said they thought this legislation was
of the nature that really needs to be
its own have its own life independent of
their Solid Waste committee um just a
reminder on those little couple
points and and again toer right yes I
would be more than happy to do whatever
it
takes so would
uh would the committee be amenable to
this bill um being replaced totally with
just uh a more brief
uh
request for Dees to do A needs
assessment or I mean I mean other than
that you know I would suggest and I
think we all are on the same page of of
wanting to do do something um to achieve
the goal of not only what Dees is
looking for but also what the solid
waste working group is looking for and
what this committee has also said in
terms of wanting to seek ways in which
we can
uh address the issue of need of um of
waste
reduction um so I mean I might even you
know entertain the idea of just itl the
bill and then request to send a letter
from this committee to Solid Waste
working group saying hey this was Sample
legislation would your committee
consider looking into this issue and
making some suggestions for future
legislation representative BL brard I'd
certainly be in favor of that Madam
chair I think it's a brilliant
idea
representative Duty uh yeah I would be
totally against that uh first of all if
we do A needs assessment and we uh send
it over to Dees the first thing they're
going to come back is saying it's going
to cost us
$250,000 and where are we going to get
the money so everything is going to be
dead in the water my preference is for
uh inter room
study representative Howard I just have
a question if we give it to the uh Solid
Waste committee um will we get it back
or do they
they
they they
would no the solid waste working group
would then consider this as something
for them to to take on and to take a
look at I mean I can't speak for
representative eel or what plans she has
for 2024 and what they're studying and
looking at but certainly if we can give
them something to start with uh and and
they can discuss it amongst um both the
representative from Dees representative
from the Senate all the producers and
and solid waste haulers and other people
that at least there's more input into
that process than there would be in an
interim study um
and you know that would be something
at representative Bixby yeah so before
we say we're going to kick it over Solid
Waste working group uh we should make
sure that there's someone who there that
they actually want to receive it uh and
I think that um another possibility is
that we could do an interim study on
this and we could in uh involve the
solid waste working group as one of our
expertise okay any other comments
okay I think uh we are done talking
about
16:30 and we can move on to HB
11184 and I want to thank the committee
members for um all of your attention on
all of these bills as the hour is
getting late um we've got some real good
conversation going on and I appreciate
that uh hb1 1184 relative to making an
appropriation to The Organic
certification
program
um okay on one hand I think I don't
think there's a member on this committee
that is unfriendly or against our
organic farmers in this state I think
that um we all support organic gardening
and organic farming organic
produce uh I do think that we have some
differences of
opinion of um what that support should
look
like
um I know from testimony from um
commissioner Jasper from
agriculture he doesn't believe this bill
if it if it wasn't passed that it would
harm New Hampshire
farming
um he also said that people can put New
Hampshire Gran on their packaging if
they were to get certified in some other
place other than from the New Hampshire
agriculture
Department he said that the fees
alone would not be able to support this
program even if they were to continue
uh with I guess the appropriation that
they were looking for was an additional
additional
$220,000 for this year for this
year um they already have three people
doing this the problem is that um I
guess with
the commission that he's the advisory
Council that he has been working with
has said to him that this program needs
to be funded more
robustly if they were to continue doing
it um we have 4,000
Farms 66 of them are uh certified in
state and um I guess we are one of 12
states that have an uh an
organic uh state
program
um the people who want to continue this
program mentioned that they have a
familiarity with our
inspectors Department of Agriculture is
familiar with New Hampshire Farm issues
and New Hampshire should support its New
Hampshire organic
farmers so given that I think that uh we
can start some discussion about this
particular B representative
Duty yeah I I what you said I think is
is really true I mean I think we all
want to support the organic farmers and
I'm you know in up in the air about this
I mean I I do see it as a marketing
program but I do think that it's
important what about the possibility
okay I'm going to throw it out again of
maybe doing an interim study and working
with our federal delegation to see if
there's any funding program
that uh would be available for let's say
the next 5 years uh to be able to fund
it um I I don't know I mean you know I
mean it's it's hard to take money from
the general fund for a small slice of
Farmers on the other hand I just don't
want to leave them high and dry so I'll
throw that out representative ktoa thank
you madam
chair um as the commissioner said they
wouldn't be left high and dry you know
the misnomer that he left the dairy and
the meat uh Farmers high and dry was was
false um they chose not to they had you
know over six months we also know that
there's substantial number of Organic
Crop Farmers that are being certified
not by the
state we also
know
that through the USDA they can recoup up
to 75% % of the fees that it cost them
to be organ organic up to
$750 and as you know that was stated the
cost for some was $900 and the other
cost was
$1,400 they have not seen a fee increase
in this state and they were paying $300
to be certified so if you take
300 and 75% of $1,400 it might cost them
another $100 or $200 is to be certified
by
mafka the other thing is is that
top which is USDA organic transition is
GI working with Farmers with a $100
million grant program already for
organic
farming my personal
opinion is that they need to either
self- sustain this
program because we should shouldn't be
favoring less than 2% of
else representative NAB thank you madam
chair um you know it's I know I've only
been on this committee for a year but
it's my feeling that we are very
supportive of farmers unless US unless
it costs us any money so I I just want
to be and I understand that we're trying
to be fiscally conservative but I also
want to be really careful and say no to
supporting this um and it so I'll say
that and I'll also point out that
organic farmers it's not just marketing
like organic farming is better for the
soil it's better for our insect
populations it's better for our bird
populations it's better for our
consumers there are pieces of it that
are better as a whole for our state and
for our constituents that are not it's
not just better for the farmers you know
it's not just we're not just doing this
for the organic farmers I think it it
plays a much bigger role in our
environment I think it's important to
remember that when we're thinking about
this so I take everything that the chair
said I I totally agree that it's a
complicated issue but um I just wanted
to say those two points thank you
representative
Howard I thought one of the uh
interesting testimonies was that um many
organic farmers were going outside the
state to get their to get their
certification and um it seems sort of
like a viable option to me and I I sort
of could picture things with you know
certified organic and grown in you know
two different stickers side by side um
because I I think the sticker price on
high representative Bixby did you have a
comment yeah so
um my
my my feeling about this is that uh this
is something that uh would be so the the
the appropriation on this I think is
essential I see it as Bridge funding so
that the um the depart the program in
the department can continue long enough
to provide a solid basis for the for the
uh for the farmers who are now in that
program so that a um a more robust
program can be worked out in the next
couple of years uh at this point uh
there have been some attempts to figure
out a way to get a uh a satellite
program using uh
with with essentially a New Hampshire
base but having a third party uh um
certifier be the um be the the uh Point
organization with the
USDA uh and that process is still very
much in um in the discussion phase it is
they don't have a solid commitment from
another uh certifier yet that would say
say that would be possible uh so it's
something that they're still exploring
it would it also requires on NOA to get
a uh to spin off a separate uh LLC
because under USDA
rules uh the NOA would as as an advising
organization cannot be the certifying
organization so uh there's a lot of
there's a lot of work in terms of uh
trying to hammer out an agreement that
will be best for New Hampshire's organic
farmers uh it's not going to gel in the
next six months and I think what what
this bill does is it really
buys another year for NOA and the
department and uh other reg Regional
organizer or certifying organizations
who might be able to cooperate with NOA
to create us a more solid working plan
representative Bixby if I recall
commissioner said that he would continue
this program till the end of the year if
we did not pass this legislation yes
that gives us so that gives us to the
end of this growing season uh which
still is a very tight timeline for what
uh no is trying to pull together in
terms of uh creating a satellite program
uh so I think that uh fund Prov in this
funding for the Department to uh which
would be supplemented by fees and their
fees are going to increase uh in the
next for the 25 growing season uh that
will um I think uh give no for the the
time to pull together a a more solid uh
plan uh for the future going forward
representative
smart yeah I just wanted to speak to the
point point of organic farmers are
better for the soil and better for the
environment than regular Farmers um our
soil and our land is our job security
and we have regulations that we have to
follow as Farmers whether we're organic
certified or not and um no I don't know
any farmer who wants to go out of his
way
to do damage to his crops or his soil or
his animals or anything to that effect
just because he doesn't have a
USDA um certified organic farmer in New
Hampshire signed to put on his food as
far as I can tell what I see is they get
more money for their produce um but that
doesn't necessarily mean they had better
practices for their
now I forgot what I was gonna say okay
well we'll go to representative ger then
and when you when you remember let me
know thank you madam chair I apologize I
just step out for a moment at the
beginning of this conversation but I
just wanted to reiterate a point I made
during the hearing which is I I hope
that the fee structure will will be
Revisited it seemed to me that was an
issue too if if they're going by the
income of the farmer right now going
right on the S so the number of Acres
but that doesn't correspond to the
income of the farmer so I just hope that
as a part of whatever solution we end up
with that that that fee structure gets
Revisited so that is the fee structure
and the the authorization to uh work out
the fee structure is something that is
in current law and uh that's something
that's not really part of this
bill yeah I no I understand that I just
wanted to say I wanted to put that out
there because I don't think whatever
solution we end up with is is going to
be satisfactory unless we also address
the issues with the fee structures it
exists thank you representative Penza
okay I remember now um so to the point
that representative Bixby made in
regards with NOA so they would have to
uh if you can clarify they would have to
like break off or do something as a
separate entity to be able to um be a
certifier yes so under USDA organic
rules the
organization that provides advice and
advocacy uh for uh organic farmers
cannot be the same organization that
certifies so mafka actually is two
different branches there's the main
organic farmers and gardeners
Association which does uh advising and
does advocacy and uh education stuff and
then there's mafa certif certification
Services which is a separate
LLC that uh just does the certification
and uh there they have entirely separate
accounts uh the only support that the
certification Services gets from the
main organization is that it um they
they have some uh workspace available on
the the mafka campus that uh that so but
other than that they're financially
completely separate representative
cont thank you madam chair and um
correct me if I'm wrong representative
Bixby but because we're looking at um
fiscal year
2025 funding this not this year could
that then fall under the budget
process uh no it's so 20 fiscal year
2025 is within is in this bium and then
any future future funding would be under
the budget process if that were deemed
appropriate
followup
um there's nothing in this bill to
sustaining at the same time uh being
able to so
um that's uh that's something that we
can revisit during the budget process
for the next
bill okay
um is there any plan for any kind of
amendments to this bill represent vict I
don't plan any amendments I think that
it is uh it it it either stands on its
merits as it is or it doesn't and U I
think that uh that's something that
we'll decide on representative K's um
um yeah I I mean I recall that Rob
Johnson from from Farm Bureau had
mentioned that um he thought that there
should be some sort of sunset provision
on the funding uh for the or Organic
certification program to give it some
time and then if it didn't work out then
at least you had a sunset provision okay
would you would um I could put together
a an amendment I could work with you on
an amendment to uh for a potential
Sunset if you'd be amendable to that
okay well um we'll we'll have to discuss
that yeah um but I do know the sentiment
of uh some folks on the committee who
have said to me that you know if if we
already have a mechanism in place where
farmers can get certified
organic then why would the Department of
Agriculture duplicate that effort I mean
that that's been the question that's
kind of come up yeah I I and I I hear
that argument um and uh I also heard a
lot of constituents who were very
um
very um what's
it
very dedicated to having the program
continue within the department and uh so
I'm
essentially I said I told them I would
repr that represent them in this
process and but I wonder though I mean
if that meant that the fees on this
program would be increased which is
probably more likely because of the need
to have more income for for this I
wonder if there I mean there are only 66
Farms right now that are with the
current program and the current fee
structure and I wonder how many of those
would drop off if the fees went
up that's a reasonable question uh but I
think we're not we're not going to solve
it today right represent comto thank you
madam chair and I just want to reference
the question that you just asked and
what we heard from the folks that were
testifying is that they would go
somewhere else yeah I just represent
Craton and then I think we'd be done
with this yeah I'm just trying to square
um 4,000 people or 4,000 Farms versus 66
and why we would be spending
$220,000 for 66 Farms just to do
something that's already been done and I
us all right thank you and we're gonna
move along to our last bill to uh weigh
1618 um which I just received an
amendment
for um they change it
to okay so this is uh what is this
amendment do okay so what um the uh this
essentially addresses a criticism that
the commissioner had of the um the bill
that representative wolf submitted uh
and uh the way that it was
originally constructed would have
required the department to uh cover all
four Scopes that in The Organic
certification program and that would
have been uh actually impossible for the
Department to do uh the
commissioner uh put together this
language for representative wolf as
something that uh would in fact be
workable if we chose to pass this uh
pass the Bill uh and um so essentially
what it does is that it would uh require
the current uh program uh organic
program in the department to continue uh
as it is which is just for certifying
crops uh and currently uh it's the ter
the the word may is in that in uh the
commission May which means that the
commissioner has the ability to say uh
no we can't do this anymore uh this
would uh make it a shall which means
that only the legislature would be able
ktoa oh I to you m' oh okay thank you
madam chair um this bill is almost a
duplication of the previous Bill except
that it puts it in law and there's
doesn't talk about self being
self-funded at all and again you're
talking less than 2% of the Farms would
benefit while the rest of us do
kraton uh yes ma'am I just to be clear
and it's really asking the question is
is this duplicative of the previous bill
number one and number two it what would
the the last Financial note on this was
800,000 and what is this a quarter of
that I don't okay so
uh well you don't get you don't get um
fiscal notes on on amendments but but
the the the cost to the Department of of
this would be uh in the first year the
220,000 that is in the previous Bill uh
it is a an entirely separate bill from
my bill uh and uh so uh I am essentially
bringing forth this amendment as uh as a
favor for representative wolf um whose
Bill the the bill is um
and uh he is he is an organic farmer
himself and he uh was uh very much he
was affected by the loss of the um Pro
the handling and animal Scopes in the um
a couple years ago when those uh ended
up disappearing and he just does doesn't
want to have the crop scope disappear
again uh so uh in terms of the cost of
this it is um it it would be the 220,000
the first year and less than that in the
following years because there are
capital expenses in the um in the that
first year fiscal note um and it my it
should be considered separately from my
bill okay for a followup ma'am yep and
so yes
separately but I thought you just said
it was the same two bodies that we were
buying for that
220,000 so the um there's no there's no
difference so there's no if if my bill
passes there this bill has absolutely no
additional cost to your bill to my bill
so uh if my bill if my bill fails and
this bill passes then uh the cost would
probably be about that about what my
bill was okay thank you sir representing
com tomor thank you madam chair just to
clarify if this bill
passes there's no reason to put a sunset
into the previous bill because it will
never
Sunset that's correct representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair um I'm
trying to think about an analogy to why
I think Organics are so important I pay
for public schools but I sent my kids to
private schools I pay for a lot of
things I don't live on Great Bay but I
care desperately about that body of
water so yes Organics cost more yes
there are fewer organic farmers by far
but they are producing something
precious and I believe our our soil our
water our air all benefit from that as
my colleague um representative NAB said
I attest to
that representative kto thank you than
you madam chair just because you're not
certified organic doesn't mean you're
not organic um so there is a difference
in the organic farmers in the farmers
that practice IPM and no till management
and other best practices on their Farms
also contribute just as much as your
certified organic
farmers okay as we
um so for the this particular
Bill what I see is that it it's it's
more of a mandate to the uh Department
of
Agriculture that's correct and it says
basically whether the organic program is
of Ben well I don't want to it would the
Organics organic programs the organic
Community does benefit New Hampshire I
don't want to say that it
doesn't but if um and I would never say
that because it does I mean organic
farming is important it is an important
element of our farming and agricultural
endeav but what I see with this bill is
that it is forcing the
commissioner to run a program whether
that program is successful or not and I
and I see that that's a problem I I
would rather leave this as a May than a
shall rather than
um uh forcing us to have a program that
may or may not be successful or
beneficial to the organic
community and if something better comes
along um we still have to be required to
run a program that would be ineffective
or not not beneficial to to the farming
community and that's why I'm I I have an
opposition to changing the words made a
shell
representative H Haskins I'd like to ask
um representative Bixby how much
confidence he has that this program
effective
um I
am uh I'm not entire I I don't have a
solid sense of
that and um I uh I am bringing forth
this amend
because um representative wolf asked me
to and uh I am not going to speak
against his bill but uh thank you you
can you can stop right
there no but then you know so I take a
look at this and I say well we have
right now an organic program in New
Hampshire it is the least expensive of
the three that are around or the few
that are around and yet we only have 66
Farms that are engaged in
it so I'm I'm just not sure
that that it's gonna be any benefit to
this representative kouan takeing my
question um so I can tell you from
personal experience that younger farmers
are migrating away from USDA certified
organic and so I kind of take issue with
this bill because there are non USDA
options now like certified naturally
grown and of certified regeneratively
grown so we should not be mandating
organic I don't think it if anything if
like we should be uh you know setting up
a hub
to point people toward whatever
certification that they feel is best I
think uh so I don't like this bill if I
had to pick one of the two I would pick
representative bixby's but I don't think
it's fair to mandate uh certified
organic any other questions
comments okay it's 4:30 let's go home
thank you and thank you again uh
committee for um all of our comments
civil conversation and uh really good
points that you all bring up
cross
m